Programming Throwdown, Episode 187, Agentic Coding. Take it away, Jason. Hey, everybody. Okay, so quick intro topic here. I was talking to a lady. I won't use her name, but let's call her a Jane. I was talking to Jane, a friend of mine.
Programming Throwdown，第187期，代理式编程。开始吧，Jason。嘿，大家好。好的，先来个简短的开场话题。我之前和一个女士聊过，我不提她的名字，就叫她Jane吧。我和我的朋友Jane聊了聊。
And she has been at her company, which is kind of like a hardware company. So it's not really Jane's specialty. It's a hardware company that needs, some software, right? And, you know, Jane's unhappy there. And there's all sorts of reasons why Jane's unhappy. It's understandable.
她在一家公司工作，那是一家类似于硬件的公司。所以这并不是Jane的专长。那是一家需要一些软件支持的硬件公司，对吧？而且，你知道，Jane在那里很不开心。Jane不开心是有各种原因的。这是可以理解的。
And she's at nine months. And so they have a one-year cliff. And so she has to kind of tough it out for three more months. And it just made me think about vesting schedules. Because I think that companies, you know, haven't really thought this through. There's like a cargo cult mentality where, you know, oh, this company did, you know, this type of vesting schedule, so we're just going to copy them. And I think some bad behavior has been copied. And when you start breaking it down, it never really makes sense.
她已经工作了九个月。他们有一年的悬崖期（cliff）。所以她还得再熬三个月。这让我思考起归属权（vesting）时间表的问题。因为我觉得公司并没有真正想清楚这一点。这就像是一种“货物崇拜”心态，你知道，哦，那家公司用了这种归属时间表，所以我们也照搬。我觉得一些不良行为就这样被复制了。当你开始剖析它时，它根本就说不通。
And so I'll start by criticizing the one-year clip. You want to explain what it is, though? Not everybody. Oh, yeah. Okay. So, okay. If you're in, let's like, wind it back. If you're in, let's say, sales, you get a commission, right?
所以，我先从批评一年悬崖期开始。不过，你想解释一下它是什么吗？不是每个人都……哦，对。好的。那么，如果你是在，让我们回溯一下。如果你是在，比如说，销售部门，你会拿到佣金，对吧？
So you build a portfolio of companies that want, you know, some product and you get a commission. And if you're doing some service-based sales, then you could potentially get a commission every single year. You can have a customer that is going to use your service for the next 20 years. But because you were the salesperson that, like, got the deal, you will just keep getting commission for 20 years, potentially. that's how sales works right and so for engineering and other fields you know they want to have an incentive structure but you know it doesn't make sense for us to do commission because we're not that close to the customer so what they'll do in our case is they will give equity so they'll say if it's a private company or if it's you know yeah not a public company they might give you a percentage of the company you might get options you might get RSUs or shares. If it's a public company, you're going to get shares. And the way this becomes an incentive is they price the shares based on your start date.
所以你建立了一个客户群，他们想要某种产品，然后你就能拿到佣金。如果你做的是某种基于服务的销售，那么你可能每年都能拿到佣金。你可能有一个客户在未来20年里都会使用你的服务。但因为你是那个谈成这笔交易的销售人员，你可能在20年里一直拿到佣金。销售就是这样运作的，对吧？所以对于工程和其他领域，他们想要一种激励结构，但我们做佣金并不合理，因为我们离客户没那么近。所以他们会做的是，在我们的案例中，他们会提供股权。如果是私营公司，或者不是上市公司，他们可能会给你公司的一定比例，你可能会得到期权、限制性股票单位（RSU）或股份。如果是上市公司，你会得到股票。这种激励方式是，他们根据你的入职日期来定价。
So for example, if a company's stock is trading for $80 a share, they're going to tell you, okay, for the next four years, you're going to get this much number of shares. you know, every month or every three months or there's some schedule, right? But let's say the price jumps up to $160 a share. Let's say the price doubles. You're still getting that number of shares. And so you can end up in a position where if the company does well, even if you, you know, don't get more equity later on,
例如，如果一家公司的股票交易价格为每股80美元，他们会告诉你，好的，在接下来的四年里，你将获得这么多数量的股票。你知道，每个月或每三个月，或者有某种时间表，对吧？但假设价格跳涨到每股160美元。假设价格翻了一番。你仍然得到同样数量的股票。所以你最终可能会处于这样一种境地：如果公司表现良好，即使你后来没有获得更多的股权，
just that one grant could double in how much you're getting every month just because the company did well. And so it aligns your incentives with the company's incentives. Okay, so that's equity. Now, you know, they're not going to give you four years of equity right on day one, right? Because you would just leave, right? Like any rational person, if they said, here's four years of, you know, up front money, and there's no strings attached, well, then, yeah, you would just go to every single company
仅仅那一次授予的股票，每个月你得到的价值就可能翻倍，仅仅因为公司表现好。所以这让你的激励与公司的激励保持一致。好的，这就是股权。现在，他们不会在第一天就给你四年的股权，对吧？因为你会直接离开，对吧？就像任何理性的人一样，如果他们说，这是你四年的预付资金，而且没有任何附加条件，那么，是的，你会去每一家公司，
collecting four years and work for a month. or something, right? So obviously, so they're going to space it out. Makes a ton of sense. Now, where I think a lot of companies go wrong is they have this one-year cliff, which means that for the first 12 months, you won't get any equity. And then after 12 months, they will give you the past 12 months worth of equity right then and there. And then you'll start accruing, you know, monthly or quarterly or something like that. I think this came about if, I mean, I have done the sort of historical work on this, but I think this came about back when, you know, a lot of these companies were very small. And so each person, you know, had to be, you know, a line item on
领完四年的钱，然后只工作一个月，或者类似的事情，对吧？所以很明显，他们会把时间拉长。这非常有道理。现在，我认为很多公司出错的地方在于他们设置了一年的悬崖期，这意味着在前12个月里，你不会得到任何股权。然后在12个月后，他们会一次性给你过去12个月的股权。然后你才会开始按月或按季度等方式累积。我认为这起源于——虽然我没有做过这方面的历史研究，但我认为这起源于很多公司规模还很小的时候。所以每个人都必须是资本结构表（cap table）上的一个条目。所以当你是一家小公司时，你有所谓的资本结构表。它列出了谁是你的投资者，基本上就是所有拥有你公司股份的人。所以，我想公司是想在不让资本结构表充斥着那些可能只工作几个月就不合适的人的名字的情况下，试用一下员工。这可能是灵感来源。也许你可以争辩说，这节省了一些钱，因为那些在一年内离开的人，你不需要付给他们那么多，对吧？这就是背后的想法。实际上，这有点像那个笑话，共产主义……
your capital table. So when you're, when you're, you know, a small company, you have what's called a cap table. And it lists out, you know, who are your investors, basically all the people who own parts of your company. And so, you know, I guess companies wanted to sort of try people out without polluting their cap table with all these names of all these people who, you know, after a couple of months, it wasn't a good fit. That might be the inspiration. Maybe you could argue that it, you know, saves a bit of money because people who leave before a year, you know, you don't have to pay them as much, right? So that's the idea behind it. In practice, it's kind of like, you know, that joke was it like communism
在理论上行得通，但从来没有……你有听过这个说法吗？从来没有被正确应用过？就像是……是的，是的，有一些说法，我们这里不太擅长政治。
like works in theory but it's never do you have the saying have you heard the same it's never been applied right it's like something yeah yeah yeah there's some saying yeah we're not we're not good at politics here
但确实有某种说法，比如“哦，共产主义行得通，那只是不是真正的共产主义”。所以这些事情都是这样，悬崖期从来没有真正按这种方式执行。我工作过的每一家公司，都有人因为某种原因在一年内离开了。
but there's some kind of saying where it's like oh communism works that just wasn't true communism it's like so it's all these things where like the cliff never actually is implemented this way every single company I've worked at you know there have been people who, for one reason or another, had to go within a year.
每一次我们都按比例分配了他们的股权。在我的整个职业生涯中，我从来没有见过有人，比如说，工作了六个月。六个月后，我们决定他们不合适，或者进行了裁员之类的，而我们没有给那个人六个月的股权。所以它有点像一根大棒，但从来没有真正被使用过。然后另一方面，你有像Jane这样的情况，她必须再坚持三个月。所以这就是为什么我对悬崖期有这种抱怨。你对一年悬崖期有什么看法？我的意思是，我工作了很久，从来没见过那种“哦，在第一年里你会以某种方式了解这个人”的情况。我的意思是，我从来没见过人们直接说“哦，这行不通，让我们在第一年之前解雇他们，这样我们就不用付钱了”。我想这……
Every single time we prorated their equity. I have never, in my entire career, seen a time where somebody, let's say, worked six months. After six months, we decided they weren't a good fit or there was a reduction in force or what have you, and we didn't give that person the six months of equity. So it's kind of like a stick, but it's never really used. and then on the flip side you have cases like Jane here where you know she has to kind of stick around for three more months so and that's why kind of rant on on on close what's your take on one year clips i mean i guess i've worked a lot and i've never seen the fact that like oh in the first year you're going to like somehow learn something about the person or like i i mean i've never seen people just be like oh this isn't working let's go let them go before the first year as like a that way we don't have to pay them which i guess
会是员工的恐惧，但我总体上从来没见过有人在一年内被解雇，因为你会给他们一个适应期，无论如何，当你熬过那个阶段，然后觉得“哦，他们真的不适合”，大多数大公司的解雇流程足够长，他们很容易就会超过一年。所以如果他们决定留下，他们就能熬过去。所以听到你关于按比例分配的故事，这是一个很好的观点。我觉得，就像你说的，这只是一个刻板的模板，而且可能在法律上已经经过了足够的测试，以至于他们不敢做任何不同的尝试。此外，通过设置更长的，比如四年归属时间表，而不是……
would be like the fear as an employee but i've just in general never seen someone let go in under a year like because it's you kind of give them a period of ramp up whatever and by the time you kind of like get through that and you're like oh they're really not sticking around the process to sort let them go at most big companies is long enough that they'll get past a year easily so if they decide to stay they'll make it um and so that's a good point hearing that between your pro rating story. It's just, I think, yeah, like you said, I feel like it's just a stamped out template and it's probably been, you know, legally tested enough that they're hesitant to, you know, do something different. It also, by having the longer, you know, like the four year vesting schedule rather
只给一年，然后每年重新发放，我认为这是为了希望股票会增长，并给你一种——这不像黄金降落伞，但有时人们称之为“手铐”或“黄金手铐”。希望是价格上涨，因此你不想离开，因为你在其他地方得不到同等的薪酬方案。但我必须说，就在最近，
than just giving something for one year and then just regiving it each year, you know, as like over the next 12 months, I think is for hope that the stock will grow and sort of give you, it's not like a golden parachute, but. sometimes people refer to as like handcuffs or golden handcuffs, is that the hope is the price goes up, and therefore you don't want to leave because you wouldn't get an equivalent pay package somewhere else. But I will say just very recently,
很多软件即服务（SaaS）公司出现了巨大的股价下跌，因为正如我们今天要谈到的，人工智能工具正在推出，人们对未来的收益感到紧张。所以有很多员工基本上想要逃离或离开，因为这是他们薪酬的很大一部分。我的意思是，在很多地方，它可以超过50%，很容易达到30%，这是你工资中非常大的一部分。
a lot of software as a service companies had a really huge stock decline as like AI tools, like we're going to talk about today, are rolling out because people are nervous about future earnings. And so there's a lot of employees who are, looking to basically bail or leave because huge portion of their compensation. I mean, a lot of places, it can exceed 50%, it's easily 30%, like it's a very big portion of your salary.
而这些上市公司的员工只是把它当作现金。所以事实上它不是，我的意思是，我很乐意深入探讨它的金融博弈论，但也许下次吧。即使它作为RSU发行，也确实是一种会计技巧，基本上是说……华尔街同意将该成本与工资成本区别对待。因此，将RSU作为单独的条目看起来会好一点。所以如果你把所有这些都去掉，它只是另一种支付员工的古怪方式。大多数公司已经有了股票购买计划，对吧？你可以……
And people at these public companies just treated as cash. So the fact that it's not, in fact, like, does it very happy to get into the finance game theory of it, but maybe for another time, even the fact that they're issued as our issues is really an accounting trick to basically say. that basically Wall Street agrees to treat that cost different than a salary cost. And so therefore, it looks a little bit better to have our issues as a separate line item. And so if all those things you got rid of, it's just another sort of quirky way of paying people. Most companies already have a stock purchase program, right, where you can either, you know,
被鼓励或以折扣价用部分工资购买股票。所以他们已经有各种方式与公司建立共同所有权。是的，我真的认为现在是时候进行彻底改革了，但随着这些颠覆性的变化，如果人们真的担心会发生什么，那么将部分薪酬从基于股票的改为基于现金的，对于上市公司来说是可能的。这就是上市的意义，对吧？这些东西是按市值计价的。对于既没有现金也没有可靠市场价值的初创公司来说，这要困难得多。是的，完全正确。还有另一件事，在某些特定类型的公司中变得流行。这就是10-20-30-40的归属时间表。我从来没有在有这种制度的地方工作过。
encouraged or get a discount to buy stock with a portion of your salary. So there's various ways they already get sort of joint ownership with the company. Yeah, I really think it's sort of time for a revamp, but it's possible to happen with these disruptions where if some companies are really, like if people are really worried about what's going to happen, then shifting some compensation from, you know, stock based to cash based for public companies. That's the point of being public, right? Is that these things are like mark to market. That's much harder for a startup that either doesn't have the cash or doesn't have a reliable market value. Yeah. Yeah, totally right. And then the other thing which like kind of got popular in like a certain niche of companies. Is this like 10, 20, 30, 40 investing schedule? So this, I've never worked at a place that has this.
亚马逊绝对是最著名的。我想Snapchat有一段时间也用过这个，虽然我想他们已经放弃了。但想法是，你会得到……如果你授予的股份是100股，为了简单起见，第一年你得到10股。第二年你得到20股，第三年30股，最后一年40股。所以它会把股权后置。我从来没理解过这一点。我一直觉得不应该是相反的吗？
Amazon is definitely the most famous. I think Snapchat had this for a while, although I think they abandoned it. But the idea was that, you would get, you would get 10. So if your grant is, let's say, 100 shares to make it simple, you get 10 of those shares your first year. You get 20 the second year, 30, the next year and 40 the final year. And so it would kind of backload the equity. I never understood that. I always felt like shouldn't it be the opposite?
因为第一年，你知道，你没有任何刷新（refresher）之类的。所以这对我来说从来没有意义。这是一个让我感到困惑的问题。我真的不知道他们为什么要那样做。我的意思是，人们愤世嫉俗地说，哦，这是因为我认为亚马逊的平均任期很短。所以平均任期，好吧，这里跑题了，但人们说大厂（FANG）的平均任期是四年。但实际上比那长得多。那只是如果你测量所有已经离开的人，对吧？
Because the first year, you know, you don't have any refreshers or anything. And so it never really made sense to me. That's one that just boggles me. I really don't know why they do that. I mean, people have said cynically, oh, it's because I think the average tenure at Amazon is very low. So the average tenure, okay, kind of side rant here, but like people say the average tenure at bang is four years. But it's actually much longer than that. That's only if you measure all the people who have left, right?
你不能真的那样做。你必须为那些还没有离开的人分配一个任期。如果你给他们一个无限的任期，那么整体的平均任期也是无限的，对吧？如果你给它零，好吧，如果你不计算它，那么你就会得到四年。但这两者都不太合适。所以任期相当长，你知道。
you can't really do it that way. You have to assign a tenure to the people who haven't left yet. If you give them a tenure of infinity, well, now the overall average tenure is also infinity, right? If you give it zero, well, then if you don't count it, well, then you get four years. But neither of those are really appropriate. So the tenure is pretty long, you know.
在亚马逊，人们说它是18个月左右。同样，它可能比那更长。绝对比其他公司少得多。但我觉得这可能不是他们做10-20-30-40的原因，因为他们计划在两年后解雇员工。但我认为这有点像你说的，Patrick，他们只是想出了一个东西，然后就太难改变了。我还有另一件事。
At Amazon, people said it was, I think, 18 months or something. Again, it's probably longer than that. is definitely a lot less than the other companies. But I feel like that's probably not the reason they did the 10, 20, 30, 40 would be because they plan on getting rid of people after two years. But I think it's kind of what you said, Patrick, that, you know, they just came up with something and then it's just too hard to change. I do have a separate thing.
我们应该继续。但这就像反向幸存者偏差。所以人们开始考虑编写代码来回测股票交易时，他们会采用标普500指数，也就是前500家公司，然后回顾过去。但你这样做所忽略的是……
We should move on. But it's like reverse survivorship bias. So there's this thing where people first start thinking about, you know, writing code to back test stock trading. So they take the S&P 500, you know, top 500 companies and you look back in time. But what you are missing out by doing that
股票指数会随时间变化。所以如果你采用今天存在的公司，你并没有看到所有失败的公司。所以如果你想回到10年前并向前推演，你需要从10年前存在的公司集合开始，而不是今天存在的公司集合。因为当你回到过去时，
is like the stock index changes over time. So if you take companies that exist today, you're not looking at all the companies that have failed. So if you want to go 10 years ago and play forward, you need to start with the set of companies that were in existence 10 years ago, not the set of companies in existence today. Because when you go backwards in time,
你会失去那些还没有开始的公司，这没关系，但你也会失去那些失败的公司，这影响巨大。所以他们称之为幸存者偏差。就像二战中返回的飞机，分析它们哪里有弹孔，却忽略了那不是你应该修补弹孔的地方。关于这个有一个著名的梗，对吧？因为你知道那些坠毁的，对吧？那些才是关键。但这些……就像你在计算任期时提到的，我之前没意识到。所以除非你的公司像超级老牌公司那样，人们退休了等等，否则你不会达到……
you're going to lose companies that haven't, yet started, but that's fine, but you're also going to lose companies that failed, which is hugely impactful. And so they call that survivorship bites. The same thing as planes, which returned from World War II and analyzing where they had bullet holes misses the fact of like, that's not where you should patch up the bullet holes. There's like a famous meme about this, right? Because you know the ones that went down, right? Like those are the ones. But these come up like you were sort of mentioning in tenure computation, which I didn't actually realize. So unless your companies like super old to where people retired and everything, you don't like sort of reach
稳态。然后你就无法解释这种波动。我看到的另一个例子是，有人在谈论我们之前讨论过的开始跑步和学习跑步之类的事情，也许不是在我们年轻的时候。人们在谈论波士顿马拉松的参赛资格标准，你必须在马拉松中跑得相当快。他们谈论的是在获得波士顿马拉松资格之前需要训练的年数。但他们只能选取那些已经获得波士顿马拉松资格的人，并说他们训练了多久。但像我，我跑了几年。第一，我离资格还差得远。即使我的目标是获得资格，我也不知道我能不能做到。这需要……
steady state. And then you then you can't account for for sort of flux. The other one I saw it is someone was talking about, you know, we've talked previously about starting to run and learning to run or whatever, you know, maybe not when we were younger. And people are talking about this standard of qualifying for the Boston Marathon where you have to run pretty fast in a marathon. And they were talking about the number of years it takes to, like train before you qualify for the Boston Marathon. But they could only take people who had qualified for the Boston Marathon and saying how long they trained for. But like me, I've run for a few years. One, I'm not anywhere close to qualifying. And even if it was my goal to qualify, I don't know that I could. It just takes a
大量的努力才能达到。而且我并没有特别的天赋。所以即使我把它作为目标并训练了10年，我也永远不会出现在数据中。那么说平均人们需要两年是什么意思呢？那是平均那些成功的人在两年内成功了，对吧？那么那些没有成功的人呢？你必须把那个数字放进去，否则，除非你知道这会发生在你身上，否则你不知道这是否是一个有效的统计数据。
lot of work to get there. And I'm not particularly naturally talented for it. So I would never show up in the numbers, even if I had it as a goal and trained for 10 years. So what does it mean to say on average people took two years? It's on average people who succeed. succeeded in two years, right? Like, what about all the people who didn't? You have to put that number in? Or else, unless you know that's going to happen to you, you don't know if that's a valid statistic.
是的，我们称之为第二类错误或假……哦，那是个名字。很好。是的，所有那些你从未看到过的出错的事情。所以所有那些没有获得波士顿马拉松资格的人，因为他们扭伤了脚踝，而你从未看到，因为他们从未申请。
Yeah, we call this a type 2 error or a false. Oh, that's a name. Good. Yes, it's all the things that, you know, that went wrong that you never saw. So all the people who didn't qualify for the Boston Marathon because they sprained their ankle and you just never saw it because they never applied.
是的。好吧。好吧，所以实际上，我们至少应该对此投个票。我的意思是，哦，抱歉，你来吧。亚马逊，不，我的意思是，好吧，一个问题是，你应该把公司列入黑名单，还是不应该申请任何公司？好吧，几乎每家公司都有悬崖期。你绕不开这个。也许，也许他们都会听我们的，然后取消悬崖期。我知道OpenAI大约在一年前取消了他们的悬崖期，他们的一年悬崖期。但好吧，所以我们无法摆脱它，但像10-20-30-40，人们还应该去那些公司吗？我想，也许这并不是最重要的事情，你知道，这不是一个……这就是我要说的，如果你在比较两家公司，我认为对于像10-20-30-40这样后置的激励措施，在适应性和可变性方面表现较差，所以这会是一个减分项，但我并不……
Yep. All right. All right. So actually, well, we should at least just put a vote on this. I mean, oh, sorry, you go for it. Amazon, well, no, I mean, so, okay, a question is, should you blacklist or should you just not apply at any company? Well, okay, almost every company has a cliff. You're not getting around that. Maybe, maybe they'll all listen to us and they'll get rid of their cliffs. I know Open AI got rid of their cliff, their one year cliff about a year ago. but okay so we're not going to get away from that but like the the 10 20 30 40 should people still go to those companies I guess it's I guess maybe it's just not the most important thing you know it's not a that's what I was going to say if you're comparing two companies I think the incentives are poor for fit and change ability for the backloaded things like 10 20 30 40 so it would be it would be a notch against but I don't
认为这是一个……如果这是进入行业、进入科技公司的途径，如果这是那些将支付你认为你应得报酬的人，那么，我不认为这是不去那里的理由。是的。我认为这很公平。除非你认为有猫腻，除非你有证据表明他们故意在一年或两年内频繁更换员工。是的，我想我们是一样的。我的意思是，我会说也许稍微强烈一点，对我来说，这绝对是一个黄牌。做10-20-30-40的公司，这绝对是一个担忧。但同样，如果你有一个好老板，一个好团队，看起来是你感兴趣的工作，那么它很容易被克服。
think it's a, if that's the way to break into the industry to get into a tech company, if that's the people that are going to, you know, pay you what you feel your worth, then like, I don't think it's a reason to not go there. Yeah. I think that's fair. Unless you think there's foul play, unless you have evidence that they're purposely churning people out within a year or two. Yeah, I think we're in the same boat. I mean, I would say maybe a little stronger, you know, for me, it's definitely a yellow flag. Uh, companies that do 10, 20, 30, 40, um, It is definitely a concern. But again, if you have a good boss, a good team, it seems like the work you're interested in, then it could easily overcome it.
好的。进入新闻。Patrick，你的新闻是什么？好的。所以我的新闻，可能大多数人，好吧，实际上，我不知道。我有点好奇。我不觉得它得到了应有的报道。但它现在已经过去了，这就是阿耳忒弥斯2号（Artemis II）任务，这是美国国家航空航天局（NASA）试图将人类送往……
All right. On to news. Patrick, what's your news? All right. So my news, probably most people, well, actually, I don't know. I'm a little curious. I don't feel like it got as much covers as just as it should. But it is now past, which is the Artemis II mission, which was the United States, NASA, trying to send people a,
不是进入轨道，而是在月球周围绕一圈。所以他们受到月球引力的影响，绕过月球背面并返回地球。这发生在我们录制节目的上周。这是一个非常令人兴奋的事情。但它最初有点，我不知道，被低估了。我想一旦它发生了，新闻报道就跟上了。但很多人只是没有谈论它。
not in orbit, but in a loop around the moon. So they were influenced by the moon's gravity to sort of slingshot around the backside of the moon and back to Earth. And this happened as of this recording, like last week. And it was a, you know, very exciting thing. But it was a little, I don't know, underappreciated initially. I think once it was happening, the news coverage kind of picked up. But a lot of people just like weren't talking about it.
它没有炒作。如果你曾经和经历过最初登月的人谈过，那已经是70年前的事了，那是全部。那是件大事。那绝对是全方位的报道。而我觉得这只是，哦，那很酷。然后人们就继续前进了。我一直在试图想出一个理论，关于为什么。
It didn't have a hype. If you ever, you know, talk to someone who was around for the original moon landings, which are now, you know, whatever, 70 years, it was everything. It was its major deal. It was like absolutely, you know, wall-to-wall coverage. And I feel this was just, you know, that's cool. And people just kind of moved on for it. And I've been trying to come up with a theory as to, you know, sort of why.
有一些原因，你知道，世界有点不同了。在政治上，我们美国这个国家，你知道，处于一种动荡之中，我想，内部事务。所以很难让每个人都团结在任何事业上。但随后我也认为，我觉得随着像星链（Starlink）和国际空间站这样的发射数量，我觉得这有点像，是的，好吧，我们一直在做这个。而且我认为人们不了解去月球和去近地轨道所需的能量差异。
And there's ones, you know, just the world is a little bit of a different place. Politically, our country here in the United States is, you know, you. you know, and a, what do you will say, a bit of turmoil, I guess, internal stuff. So it's hard to get, you know, everybody to rally on any cause. But then I think that as well, I feel with the amount of launches for things like Starlink and the International Space Station, I think it's a bit just of, it feels like, yeah, okay, we do this all the time. And I think people don't understand the sort of energy difference needed to go to the moon versus go to low Earth, low Earth orbit.
所以无论如何，我只是想为重返月球的工作点个赞。而且，你知道，是否会建立月球基地还有点争议。但绝对的，就技术演示和突破极限的能力，以及潜在地解锁大量用于制造的新资源而言，这绝对是一个激动人心的时刻。而且，你知道，距离下一次阿耳忒弥斯3号还有一段间隔。但阿耳忒弥斯2号是一次令人兴奋的观看……
And so anyways, I just want to give a shout out for, you know, the work of getting back to the moon. And, you know, it's a little controversial whether or not a moon base will be set up. But definitely, you know, as far as like technology demonstration and the ability to push the envelope, as well as potentially unlock lots of new resources for manufacturing, it's a definitely exciting time. And, you know, it's going to be a little bit of a gap before the next Artemis, Artemis 3. but, you know, Artemis II was an exciting watch
如果你有机会在期间收看的话。如果没有，YouTube上有很多回顾。回去看看发生了什么。所以他们，所以这个已经……我不关注太空。而且出于某种原因，太空也不关注我。我不推荐任何关于太空的东西。但所以整个项目开始并结束了，所以宇航员只是绕着月球弹射，
if you got the opportunity to tune in during it. If not, plenty of YouTube retrospectives. Go back and check out all that happened. So they, so this already, I don't follow space. And for some reason, space doesn't follow me either. Like I don't recommend it anything about space. But so the whole project started and ended, so the astronauts just slingshoted the moon,
回来了，每个人都很安全。是的。是的，怎么会……我的意思是，我觉得即使是我们这些非太空爱好者，也应该出现在……我有，哦，天哪，我不会长篇大论地谈论人们如何获取新闻。我通过在安卓手机上向左滑动来获取新闻，我只是得到每个人都能得到的谷歌新闻。所以，真的，那可能是一个很好的地方。是的。我，也许那是一个评论。关于人们现在进入新闻系统的个人渠道或无论你怎么称呼它，因为它们都有偏见。但我想如果你这样做，并不是说某个年龄以下的人会收看新闻，但这里自从他们发射以来，我的意思是，我住在佛罗里达，所以他们是从佛罗里达发射的。所以我们得到了一些当地的新闻报道。所以我们有时……
came back, and everyone's safe. Yes. Yeah, how did, yeah, I mean, I feel like that should, even like us, you know, non-space enthusiasts, like, that should have showed up on, I do, I have the, oh, man, I'm not going to go on a huge tangent on how people get their news. I get my news from swiping left on my Android phone and I just get the Google news that's kind of everybody gets. So like, really, that could have been a good place for it. Yeah. I, maybe that is a, maybe it's more of a commentary. on people's individual funnels or however you want to call like individual filters that we all have into our news systems now where they're all biased. But I guess if you do, not that people below a certain age, just tune into the news, but here since they launched, I mean, I live in Florida, so they launched from Florida. So we got some local news coverage of it. So we do sometimes
看当地新闻只是为了听听当地事件。但总的来说，全国新闻，在我看来有点报道不足。是的。是的，完全同意。他们成功回来了，是的。所以四名宇航员，三名来自美国，一名来自加拿大，
watch the local news just to hear, you know, local events. But yeah, in general, national news, it seemed a little undercovered in my opinion. Yeah. Yeah, totally. I fully agree. They're back successful, yeah. So four astronauts from the United States and one from Canada, so three from the United States and one from Canada,
进入了轨道，绕月球半圈。他们再次，像是在背面弹射。所以拍了很多照片。他们没有靠得特别近。他们靠得足够近，以至于在他们的视野中非常大，但他们可以看到整个东西从一边到另一边，不是特别低。所以由于离月球那么远，
went into orbit, a sort of half orbit around the moon. They went, again, like sort of slingshotted around the backside. So it took a bunch of pictures. They didn't get super close. They got close enough that it was very big in their field of view, but they could kind of see the whole thing from side to side, not super low. And so by virtue of being so far away from the moon
当他们绕过背面时，他们实际上创下了人类远离地球的最远旅行记录。哦，哇。所以如果我们要开始尝试改变《星际迷航》，他们走得比任何人类走得都远。这很酷。你知道，但说到你的观点，
when they went around the backside, they actually had a record for farthest travel for a human away from Earth. Oh, wow. And so they went further than any human has gone before if we want to start trying to change the Star Trek. That's cool. You know, but to your point,
当SpaceX的人抓住火箭时，你知道，当它降落在筷子（Chopsticks）里，或者你们叫那个东西什么。好的。是的，我看到了。那到处都是我的谷歌新闻。所以我确实认为，无论出于什么原因，这没能得到它应得的关注。同意。
when the SpaceX people caught the rocket, you know, when it landed in the chopsticks or of you all call that thing. Okay. Yeah, that I saw it. Like, that was all over my Google news. So I do think that this wasn't able to get the kind of attention to deserve for whatever reason. Agreed.
但点个赞。无论如何，你知道，我认为这是一件令人兴奋的事情。而且，你知道，我在这里是为了……有很多年轻人，他们的想象力被这些重大的技术壮举所吸引，而不是像越来越小的手机或更好的聊天机器人，对吧？我的意思是，人们将开始成年。你只是伴随着那些东西长大。所以我希望，至少即使是从深入海底，进入外太空成长起来。总有一些事情让人感觉有点特别。
But a shout out. Either way, you know, I think it's something exciting. And, you know, I'm here for the, I, there's a lot of people, young people who are, have their imagination captured by these sort of like big technological feats more so than increasingly like, yeah, another smaller, you know, phone or, you know, a better chat bot, right? I mean, people are going to start coming of age. You just grew up with that stuff. And so I'm hopeful that some of the, at least even growing up from you know, going deep under the ocean, going into outer space. There's always things to just feel a little special.
是的。是的，这很有道理。酷。好的。我的新闻故事，第一个新闻故事是Gemma 4的发布。所以Gemma是一个视觉语言模型或多模态模型系列，它们是完全开源、开放权重的，而且足够小，你甚至可以在手机上运行它们。你绝对可以在台式机或笔记本电脑上运行它们。而且我已经用Gemma 4做了一些很酷的事情。我微调了一个非常小的Gemma 4模型来尝试纠正语法。好的。而且它实际上运行得非常好。
Yeah. Yeah, that makes sense. Cool. All right. My news story, first news story is the Gemma 4 release. So Gemma is a family of vision language models or multimodal models that, um, that are totally, totally open source, open weight, and are small enough that you can even run them on your phone. You can definitely run them on your desktop or laptop. And I actually did something kind of cool with Gemma 4 already. I got it to, I fine-tuned a very small Gemma 4 model to try to correct grammar. Okay. And it actually works really, really well.
我过去尝试过非常小的模型，从来没有得到好的表现。所以我的愿景是在手机里构建一些东西，无论我在什么应用程序上，它可能是一个自定义键盘，我不知道，但它会纠正我的语法。所以它会查看我所说的全部内容，然后去修复语法问题。
I tried this in the past with really small models, and I never got good behavior. So my vision was to build something into my phone where no matter what app I'm on, it would just maybe it would be a custom keyboard. I don't know, but it would just correct my grammar. So it would look at like the entire content of what I was saying, and it would go through and fix grammatical things.
而这些模型从来都不太好，而且很难微调，等等等等。但Gemma 4实际上跨越了那个障碍，我在台式机上进行了微调。好的，关于微调的简短说明。所以，你知道，微调基本上意味着继续训练。所以即使它是一个小模型，
And the models were never very good, and they were hard to fine tune, et cetera, et cetera. But Gemma 4 actually kind of crossed that barrier where I ran through a fine tuning on my desktop. Okay, real quick thing on fine tuning. So, you know, fine tuning basically just means continuing training. And so even though it's a small model,
它之所以小是因为所有这些技巧，但这些技巧在训练时不起作用。所以把它想象成，你烤了一个饼干，然后你在上面涂上糖霜。但如果你先涂上糖霜再烤，或者如果你尝试用糖霜重新烤饼干，你知道，糖霜会变硬，而且味道不太好。
it's small because of all these tricks, but the tricks don't work at training time. So think of it as like, a, like you, you bake a cookie and then you put icing on it. But if you put the icing first and then bake it, or if you try to re-bake a cookie with icing on it, you know, the icing gets all hard and it gets kind of, you know, not very good.
所以这是两个不同的过程。所以你需要的是，可能是为了烤饼干，或者在这种情况下为了调整模型，你需要一个相当强大的配置。然后你可以稍后缩小它。所以我组装了我的台式机。我微调了这个模型。哦，是的。所以现在有很多技巧，
So it's kind of two different processes. And so what you need is to, it might be that to bake the cookie or in this case to tune the model, you need like a pretty beefy setup. And then you can sort of, you know, shrink it later. So I got my desktop together. I fine-tune this model. Oh, yeah. So there's a whole bunch of tricks now,
低秩适应（LoRA），所有这些其他技巧，即使你没有非常强大的台式机，你也可以微调它。我的还可以。它有16GB的显存，相当不错，但不足以进行纯微调。长话短说，
low-rank adaptation, all these other tricks where you can fine-tune it even if you don't have a really beefy desktop. Mine's okay. It's got 16 gigs of V-RAM, which is pretty good, but not enough to just do a pure fine-tuning. Long story short,
工具非常棒。它已经发展了很远。你现在不需要成为一个超级专家就能做这些事情。我字面上只是给了它一个我从网上得到的文本文件，一个包含大量语法错误和纠正句子的CSV。然后它就开始运行，验证损失从50%变成了80%的验证准确率。所以微调绝对起作用了。
the tooling is amazing. It's come so far. you don't have to be like a super read-in expert to do these things now. I literally just handed it a text file that I got off the web, a CSV that had a bunch of grammatical mistakes and then the corrected sentences. And then it went off and it just, the validation loss went from like 50% to 80% or validation accuracy. So the fine-tuning definitely did something.
而且它可能真的有效，所以我还没完成它，但希望我能有一些东西可以纠正每个应用程序的语法。那会很整洁。哦，那太棒了。我本来想问你是怎么得到好的训练数据的，因为如果我只给它我自己的对话，我会给它糟糕的训练数据。哦，是的，我知道。这看起来不正确。我只是上网说，嘿，我需要一个充满语法错误的巨大数据集。我找到了一个。它叫，我想是C-200
and it might actually work, so I haven't finished it yet, but hopefully I'll have something that just corrects grammar for every app. That would be pretty neat. Oh, that's awesome. I was going to ask how you got good training data because I would give it poor training data
C200M数据集。但如果你上网，查找语法错误纠正数据集，你会找到它。它是第一个结果。它拥有的语法纠正比我一生中能用到的还要多。它有大约2亿个。哦，哇。是的，我的意思是，我很想尝试微调。
if I just gave it my own conversations. Oh, yeah, I know. It doesn't seem correct. I just went online and said, hey, I need a giant data set full of grammar errors. I found one. It's called the, I think the C-200
不幸的是，我一直，我们之前讨论过这个。我玩电子游戏总是滞后。我总是玩旧的电子游戏。所以从来没有好的GPU。现在我有点，我不想要比我现有的更好的GPU，既为了玩电子游戏，也为了玩模型训练。这简直是勒索。我本来可以买一个。但我看到文章说，哦，这是500美元。然后我去eBay看，它是800美元。
C200M dataset. But if you just go online, look up a grammar error correction data set, you'll find it. It's the first result. And it's got way more grammar corrections than I'll ever use in my entire life. It's like 200 million of them or something. Oh, wow. Yeah, I mean, I would love to try the fine-tuning.
我说，不，我不做那个。抱歉。这就像是一个原则问题。我就是不能。是的。你知道，如果我必须重新开始，我会……好吧，我也用我的GPU玩游戏。但如果我没有GPU，我可能会为我使用EC2实例。是的，这就是我需要做的。这只是多了一步，多了一个……
Unfortunately, I've always, we've talked about this before. I've always lagged in playing video games. I always put older video games. So never had a good GPU. Now I kind of, I don't want a good, better GPU than one I have for both playing video games and for playing with like model training. And it's a extortion. I like I could buy one. But then I see articles saying, oh, this is a, you know, $500. And I go on eBay and it's like $800.
就像与其我花这笔钱做我想做的任何事，你知道，这就像，好的，每次我这样做，如果我犯了错误，你在心理上多付了一点钱。但你是绝对正确的。我的意思是，用租来的硬件做那些事情通常便宜得多，而且可能比你在家里拥有的硬件更好。所以，是的，这是我绝对想尝试的事情。而且我认为你采取的方法以及小模型在一般情况下运行得更快，在更多地方运行，是有道理的。所以即使你有能力运行大模型或订阅，拥有一个可以用于特定任务的小模型。我们将讨论，你知道，未来可能更多代理式的工作，让事情卸载到脚本或小模型来做。仅仅是速度，你得到的每秒Token数要快得多。
I'm like, no, I'm not, I'm not doing that. Like, I'm sorry. It's like, it's like a principled thing. Like, I just, I can't. Yeah. You know, if I had to start over, I would, uh, well, well, I use my GPU for game. too. But if I didn't have the GPU, I would probably just use an EC2 instance for me. Yeah, that's what I need to do. It's just one more step, one more, you know, unbounded.
我认为你会看到更多这种混合的东西。是的，完全同意。转个弯到下一个，新闻这次到处都是。没关系。这是一个小的，你必须点击节目说明中的链接或直接搜索。Hatris。我非常讨厌这个游戏。
Like it's rather than I spend this money and I do whatever I want, you know, it's like, okay, each time I do this, if I make a mistake, is you pay a little more psychologically. But you're absolutely right. I mean, way cheaper to do that stuff often with rented and probably better hardware than you would have at home. So, yeah, that's something I definitely would love to get into. And I think there's something to be said to the approach you're taking and like small models in general run a lot faster, run in more places. So even if you have the ability to run a big model or subscription, having like a small model that you can use for specific tasks. And we're going to talk about, you know, potentially in future more agentic sort of work, having things offloaded to scripts or to small models to do. And just the speed, the tokens per second that you get is just so much faster.
我想这就是为什么它叫Hatris。首先，我看了，我不知道是不是Summoning Salt。无论谁做，你知道，俄罗斯方块，无限分数和破碎的关卡和速通玩家。为什么我喜欢这些？我看了它们。
I think you're going to see more of that blended stuff. Yeah, totally agree. Turning the corner to yet one, the news is all over the place this time. It's okay. It's a small, you got to click the link in the show notes or just search it. Hatris. I hate this game so bad.
我想我要玩一些俄罗斯方块。我烂透了。哦，这是最糟糕的。太糟糕了。像，你知道，我像，你知道，俄罗斯方块策略。无论如何，所以我一直在玩，
I guess that's why it's named Hatress. First of all, I watch the, I don't know if it's summoning salt. Whoever does the, you know, Tetris, like infinity scores and the broken life. levels and speed runners. Why I love these? I watch them.
我想这是一个Gameboy Advance的自制游戏，Appetrus，在我有的一个小Retrooid掌机上。所以如果你感兴趣，有一个现代的诠释。所以它有一些优点。和大量的自定义。所以我一直在玩那个，但仍然很烂。所以Hatris，代替……好的，人们不知道什么是俄罗斯方块。
I'm like, I'm going to play some Tetris. I suck. Like, oh, this is the worst. It's so bad. Like, I, you know, that I'm like, you know, Tetris strategies. Anyways, so I've been playing,
有各种不同形状的碎片。有各种选择它们的方法。所以有时它可以字面上就是下一个碎片是随机的。有时它是从所谓的“抽袋”中选择的。所以他们会把所有碎片隐喻地放在一个袋子里，然后一次拿出一个。所以你等待某个碎片的最长时间是有界的。这就是更现代的诠释。Hatris反而说，
I think it's a Gameboy Advance homebrew game, Appetrus on a little retrooid handheld that I have. So if you're interested, there's like sort of a modern interpretation. So it has like some niceties. And a lot of customization. So I've been playing that a little bit, but still suck at it. So a hatred, though, instead of, okay, people don't know what Tetris is.
我要运行一个小型的，你知道，编程的、启发式的、机器学习的东西，无论什么，计算机。它会选择最糟糕的下一个碎片。所以你开始得到一个，我不知道它们叫什么，像Z形碎片。然后你一直得到Z形碎片，它们很难拼在一起。是的。
There's all the different shaped pieces. There's various ways of selecting them. So sometimes it can be literally just whatever the next pieces is random. Sometimes it's selected from what's called like a draw bag. So they'll put all the pieces in a bag metaphorically and then draw one out at a time. So you kind of, the longest you have to wait for a certain piece is bounded. that's what more sort of modern interpretations too. Hatris instead says,
但除非你强迫它进入一个有两个方式让你得分的选项。它只会给你任何不能放入你剩下的缺口的碎片。所以你必须小心地种植，更糟糕的是，它让你想多慢就多慢。对吧？
I'm going to run a little like, you know, programmed, heuristic, machine learning thing, whatever, the computer. And it's going to pick the worst next piece. So you start off getting one of the, I don't know what they're called, like the Z pieces. And you kind of just keep getting Z pieces, which are kind of hard to put together. Yeah.
我会运行一个类似编程的、启发式的、机器学习的东西，随便什么，就是计算机。它会挑选最糟糕的下一个方块。所以你一开始会得到一个，我不知道它们叫什么，比如Z型方块。然后你就会一直得到Z型方块，这种方块很难拼在一起。是的。
But then unless you force it into an option where there's two ways for you to score a line. It's just going to give you whatever piece won't arrange to fit in the notch that you have left. So you have to like carefully plant and to make it worse, it lets you go as slow as you want. Right?
但除非你强迫它进入一个有两种方式可以消除一行的选项，否则它只会给你任何无法放入你留下的缺口的方块。所以你必须小心地布局，更糟糕的是，它允许你随心所欲地慢速进行，对吧？
So you feel like this has got to be easy. But I literally, it's like getting one point and then I'm like flipping the table, excited, you know, the whole thing going off. It's amazing. But yeah, zero is where I was started. And maybe I'm just bad. So you can be like, oh man,
所以你觉得这一定很简单。但我真的，就像得了一分，然后我就像掀桌子一样兴奋，你知道，整个人都嗨了。这太神奇了。但确实，我是从零开始的。也许我只是太菜了。所以你可能会说，天哪，
that Patrick guy, like, it clearly just sucks. Like, I'm way good at this. Go play it. Maybe you'll score a lot of points, but it is enormously frustrating. I can only play for like two or three times. And then I'm like, not, I'm done. I can't. I can't.
那个叫帕特里克的家伙，显然烂透了。就像，我在这方面强多了。去玩玩看吧。也许你能得很多分，但这真的非常令人沮丧。我只能玩两三次。然后我就想，不，我不行了。我做不到。我做不到。
I've got to try it. Hatrous. If you get more than zero, don't email me because I don't want to know. Oh, man. This is so good. Yeah, I'll have to try a report back. All right. All right.
我必须试一试。Hatrous。如果你得分超过零，别给我发邮件，因为我不想知道。天哪。这太棒了。是的，我得试试并回来汇报。好吧，好吧。
He's going to be doing it well. I only go on a little monologue and give him time to play. At the end of our episode, it's like, oh, I got 10. No, dude, yeah, yeah, I'll hang up. Oh, man. All right, my second news is drip warts, school of drip. So this is a, I don't have to click the YouTube link. I already know what it is.
他会玩得很好的。我只会发表一点独白，给他时间玩。在我们这集结束时，他可能会说，哦，我得了10分。不，伙计，是的，是的，我会挂断的。天哪。好吧，我的第二个新闻是“滴水怪”，滴水学院。所以这是一个，我不需要点击YouTube链接。我已经知道那是什么了。
Do you really? Yes. Okay, so, so I play board games every Monday with a group of guys. a very fun group. And one of those showed me this. This has got to be the most viral AI video that that's been created. I mean, I don't think anything has even come close to this in terms of virality. I disagree.
你真的知道吗？是的。好吧，所以，我每周一都和一群人玩桌游。一个非常有趣的小组。其中一个人给我看了这个。这一定是目前为止最火的AI视频。我的意思是，我不认为有任何东西在病毒式传播方面能接近这个。我不同意。
I think there's been viral videos aren't clearly AI that are AI. This is the most overtly AI thing to go viral. Like, it's clear that it's not bad AI, but it's clear that it's AI. like it's, but it's clear that it's AI, like it's not real. I think there are ones that have been purported to be real that were just viral. And like, oh, okay, yeah, that's true. Yeah. I don't have evidence to be clear.
我认为有一些病毒式视频显然不是AI，但它们确实是AI。这是最显眼的AI病毒视频。就像，很明显它不是糟糕的AI，但很明显它是AI。就像，但很明显它是AI，就像它不是真的。我认为有些视频被声称是真实的，但只是病毒式传播。就像，哦，好吧，是的，那是真的。是的。我没有证据，说明一下。
So, yeah, what I mean specifically is like, this is one where the whole point is it's AI, no producer would ever make this. And we all know that. And so, and it's, it's just hilarious. Amazing. The premise is, you know, Harry Potter, but if it's, kind of like gangster style, but also like,
所以，是的，我具体的意思是，这是一个重点就在于它是AI的视频，没有制片人会制作这个。我们都知道这一点。所以，而且它，它简直太搞笑了。太棒了。前提是，你知道，哈利波特，但如果是，有点像黑帮风格，但也像，
you know, high fashion, you know, all mixed together. Very, very funny. I just burst out laughing almost immediately. This is great.
你知道，高级时尚，你知道，混合在一起。非常，非常有趣。我几乎立刻就笑喷了。这太棒了。
I mean, I feel like there, I'm actually surprised that Open AI killed SORA because I do think that there is a play there. You know, there's, you know, really like opening it up and letting the whole world think about what are funny things
我的意思是，我觉得，我其实很惊讶OpenAI砍掉了SORA，因为我确实认为那里有文章可做。你知道，有，你知道，真的像把它开放，让全世界思考什么是搞笑的事情，
that we could mash together and sharing that, that seems like super powerful. I mean, maybe that's what TikTok is going to become. Is that. Okay, but you, I don't know how much conspiracy theory, tinful how we want to go about why. Yeah, go. Go all. Okay. No, no, I also thought the same thing, because Sora was like trying to do a thing. like my kids kind of knew what it was,
我们可以把它们混搭在一起并分享，这看起来超级强大。我的意思是，也许这就是TikTok未来会变成的样子。是那样吗。好吧，但是你，我不知道我们想在“为什么”这个问题上走多远的阴谋论路线。是的，去吧。去吧。好吧。不，不，我也想到了同样的事情，因为Sora就像在尝试做一件事。就像我的孩子们大概知道它是什么，
which is always like a pretty big thing for tech. Yeah. So we don't have it in the news of the episode now because I think it's still in flight, but Anthropic has been teasing this mythos, right? Their next sort of LLM version after Opus 4-6, I guess.
这对科技来说总是一件大事。是的。所以我们现在这集新闻里没有它，因为我认为它还在开发中，但Anthropic一直在预告这个Mythos，对吧？他们继Opus 4-6之后的下一个LLM版本，我想。
And it's supposedly earth-shattering, which to be fair, they all acclaimed to be before they come out. I'm making no statement there. But the rumor is that it was sort of like 10x, more training than the last one, but that there's some sort of, do you know like the thing that happens of grocking? So when a machine learning model trains and it hits some sort of like asymptote, and it seems
而且据说它是颠覆性的，公平地说，它们在发布前都声称如此。我对此不予置评。但传言说它的训练量大约是上一个版本的10倍，但似乎有某种，你知道像“顿悟”（grocking）那种现象吗？所以当一个机器学习模型训练并达到某种渐近线时，它似乎
like it's just sort of stabilized in performance. But actually under the hood, it's sort of like self-organizing. And then it's able to like sort of reach a new level after it sort of gets through this barrier of not actually getting better loss. Right. So your loss, your validations aren't getting better, but the model is sort of actually organizing itself to the point where then it's sort of like unlocks additional capacity and then trains further. That's Patrick's non-mathematical Yeah, it's like defragmenting your hard drive kind of, and then you can it can run fast enough for you to do something else. Right. And so supposedly the rumors go that Anthropics mythos took like, whatever, 10 or 100 X what the last one did, which was already insanity, but that it was a
只是在性能上趋于稳定。但实际上在底层，它正在进行某种自我组织。然后它能够在穿过这种实际上没有改善损失的障碍后，达到一个新的水平。对吧。所以你的损失，你的验证并没有变好，但模型实际上正在自我组织，直到它解锁了额外的容量，然后进一步训练。那是帕特里克的非数学解释。是的，这就像整理你的硬盘碎片一样，然后它就能运行得足够快，让你做别的事情。对吧。所以据说传言称Anthropic的Mythos用了，不管怎样，是上一个版本的10倍或100倍的训练量，这已经是疯狂的了，但这是一个巨大的解锁，对吧？所以有所有这些缩放规则。因此它会打破那种针对训练量与性能表现的投影回归拟合。而且据说，如果这是真的，对吧，那么OpenAI就需要腾出SORA的服务，以便他们能利用额外的硬件来获得他们所需的训练预算，从而基本上不被超越。哇。是的，我的意思是，那将是了不起的。这是真的。我的意思是，公平地说，这就像是一个关于传言的传言，就像，它可能只是因为不赚钱，但感觉一定有什么原因要把它弃用，而不是等着新版本变得更好。是的，我的意思是，我，好吧，好吧，我会告诉你我的，我不知道这是否是阴谋论还是仅仅是一个理论。我的理论是，你知道，OpenAI的品牌认知度受到了很大影响，你知道，比如萨姆·奥特曼的。
huge unlock, right? So there's all these scaling rules. And so it would break the sort of projected sort of regressions fit to the sort of like how much training versus performance you get. And supposedly, if that's true, right, then Open AI needed to free up the SORA services so that they could use the additional hardware to get the training budget they needed to basically not get leapfrog. Wow. Yeah, I mean, that would be remarkable. It's true. I mean, to be fair, it's like a rumor about a rumor that is like, it could have just been it's not making money, but like it feels there had to have been some reason to sort of like deprecate it and not just wait for the new version to be better. Yeah, I mean, I well, okay, I'll tell you my, I don't know if this is a conspiracy theory or just a theory. My theory was that, you know, Open AI's brand recognition is suffering a lot, you know, like Sam Altman's.
名字认知度受到了很大影响。你看了《洋葱报》对萨姆·奥特曼的采访吗？没有。天哪，太搞笑了。我的意思是，显然完全是假的。你只能看到文字记录。没有视频什么的，但非常，非常有趣。但是，我觉得SORA是一种巨大的品牌风险。
name recognition is suffering a lot. Did you see the Onion interview of Sam Altman? No. Oh my God, it's hilarious. I mean, obviously completely fake. You only see a transcript. There's no video or anything, but very, very funny. But, and I felt like SORA is kind of a big brand risk.
就像，即使是这个哈利波特的东西，绝对搞笑。但我不认为这些品牌，你知道，瓦伦西亚，我想，路易威登，他们字面上我没买名字。我不认为他们对此感到高兴。所以我感觉他们只是在试图限制他们的风险敞口。但他们和迪士尼有很大的合作关系，对吧？就像十亿美元的潜在价值。是的，是的。
Like, even this Harry Potter thing, absolutely hilarious. But I don't think the brands, you know, Valencia, I think, Louis Vuitton, are literally I didn't buy name. I don't think they're happy with that. So I felt like they were trying to just limit their exposure. But they had a big partnership with Disney, right? Like a billion dollar like potential value. Yeah, yeah.
而这一切都消失了。这有点疯狂。我的意思是，是的，我会把它归结为同样的事情，就像即使对迪士尼来说也是品牌问题。但也许真的是计算资源的问题。我们得等着看这个新的Mythos出来时会发生什么。好吧。说到科幻小说，
And it's all just gone. It's kind of wild. I mean, yeah, I would chalk it up to the same thing, like a brand thing even for Disney. But maybe it really is the compute. We'll have to wait and see when this new mythos comes out. what's going on there. All right. Talking about science fiction,
是时候介绍本期图书了。我们要轮流介绍科学。我要介绍本期图书，杰森要介绍本期工具。所以我的本期图书，俗话说迟到总比不到好，是《挽救计划》（Project Hail Mary）。所以如果你读过《阿耳忒弥斯》，
it's time for book of the show. We're going to take turns of science. I'm going to do a book of the show, and Jason's going to do Tool the Show. So my book of the show, better late than never they say, Project Hell Mary. So if you've well-tined with Artemis,
我认为那是个巧合。好吧，快速说一下，不是想过多插嘴，但我刚开始读这本书。所以你尽量不要剧透。是的，是的。不，我会注意的。我会注意的。
which I think was coincidental. Okay, real quick, not to interject too much, but I am just starting this book. So you can't try not to spoil it. Yeah, yeah. No, I'll be good. I'll be good.
我想我总是说得太少了。但这也是，有电影，所以有预告片。很难避免。那是真的。有各种剧透级别，但我会比预告片做得更好。我认为预告片透露得太多了。但《挽救计划》是一本关于，你知道，科幻小说，关于一个，你知道，试图去，你知道，拯救垂死地球的人。
I always undershoot, I think. But it's also, there's movies, so there's trailers. It's very hard to avoid. That's true. There's like levels of spoilers, but I'll be even better than I think the trailers. I think trailers reveal too much. But Project Halmerie is a book about, you know, science fiction, about a, you know, person out trying to, you know, save a dying earth.
对。而且其中有很多内容。嗯，这有点，呃，如果你，你知道，读过安迪·威尔的另一本书，哦，为什么名字现在从我脑海中溜走了？《火星救援》，对吧？哦，《火星救援》，谢谢。我本来想说另一本火星科幻书。我想，不，那不对。嗯，谢谢。《火星救援》。有点像，对吧？就像某种，呃，基于科技科学的。呃，他在这方面做得相当不错。但也像这种充满希望的，就像，你知道，你想要支持好人，你知道，而不是像那种混乱的，你知道，
Right. And there's lots that goes into that. Um, it's a bit of, uh, if you've, you know, kind of gone through Andy Weir's other book, oh, why is the name escaping me now? The Martian, right? Oh, the Martian, thank you. I was going to say a different sci-fi Mars book. I was like, no, that's wrong. Um, thank you. The Martian. It's a little bit the same, right? It's like sort of, uh, tech science grounded. Uh, he does a pretty good job about that. But then also like this sort of hopeful, like, you know, you want to root for the good guy, you know, and not have like sort of the same chaotic, you know,
黑暗的，神秘的，阴暗的，就像，你知道，这是好是坏？你只是想支持某人。所以它有点在同一个主题里。而且我会说，我被鼓励读这本书很长时间了。你喜欢《火星救援》吗？伙计，我不知道。就像书很好。与我推荐的大多数书，我读的大多数书相比，它读起来很短。非常容易读。我最近去度假，实际上就像度假的前两天。我基本上读完了整本书。哦，哇。这包括了一次很长的飞行，你知道。离开这个国家去另一个大陆。所以那是一次很长的飞行。
black, mysterious, dark, like, you know, is this good or bad? It's just like you want to root for someone. And so it's kind of in the same same themeing. And I will say, I was encouraged the book for a very long time. Do you like the merchant? Man, I don't know. Like the book was good. It's a short read compared to most of my recommendations, most of the books that I read. Very easy read. I went on a vacation recently and actually like first two days of the vacation. I basically read the whole book. Oh, wow. It included a very long flight, you know. leaving the country going to a different continent. So it was a very long flight.
所以公平地说，好吧，那仍然读了很多。书很好。书就像，你知道，对于它本身来说相当不错。就像，你知道，不是超级深刻，但，你知道，基础扎实。我有一些问题。但是，你知道，只是在边缘地带。我通常对科学内容不是特别挑剔，除了只是说，是的，真的吗？
So to be fair, okay, it was still a lot of reading. Book was good. Book was like, you know, pretty good for what it is. Like, you know, not super deep, but, you know, well grounded. I had some issues. But, you know, just around the edges. I'm not super critical of science stuff generally, other than just being like, yeah, right?
那是，得了吧。那是，没有人能精通这么多不同的学科到这种程度。哦，是的。那太不现实了。但除此之外，你知道，情节。我猜。但我，你知道，电影，人们喜欢这部电影，但我感觉我没有像喜欢书那样喜欢电影。
That's, come on. That's, that's, nobody knows such different disciplines to this level. Oh, yeah. That's just unrealistic. But other than that, you know, plot. I guess. But I, you know, the movie, people love the movie, but I feel like I wasn't as keen on the movie as I was on the book.
书绝对比电影好，但书并没有像别人吹捧的那样好。但它太短了，仅仅为了像，有时你需要休闲的东西，对吧？就像，你可以喜欢深刻的、磨人的、这真的让我思考的东西。但然后，你知道，有时只是采取那种，我说，我对漫威电影就是那样。很多人抨击漫威电影，超级英雄电影。
The book was definitely better than the movie, but the book was not as good as it was hyped up to me. But it was so short, it's got to be worth it for just like, sometimes you need the casual stuff, right? Like, you can love the deep, grindy, this is really making me think. But then, you know, sometimes just taking that sort of like I say, I'm that way about Marvel movies. A lot of people rag on Marvel movies, superhero movies.
我想进去看一些我不需要想太多的东西，就像你知道，我不希望它是，你知道，某种深刻的沉思，你知道，在最后他是处于梦中还是他醒着，或者你知道，好吧，我不知道，不管怎样，我不想知道，只是告诉我发生了什么。是的，我和你有同感。
I want to go in and watch something I don't have to think so hard about like you know I don't want it to be you know some deep brooding you know at the end was he in the dream or was he awake or you know okay I don't I don't whatever I don't want to know like just tell me what happened yeah I'm right there with you
我的意思是，你知道，我去看电影，我和孩子们看了《超级马力欧兄弟大电影》，我想看这个。是的，是的，他们很喜欢，你必须带着正确的期望进去。你不是为了期待某种非常高概念的东西而进去的。
I mean you know I go into a movie I saw the Super Mario movie with the boys I want to see this yeah yeah they they loved it and you just you have to go in with the right expectations. You're not going in to expect something really high concept.
是的。所以《挽救计划》就像一个近未来，非常扎实，不是超级，你知道，遥远，但绝对，
Yeah. So Project Helmeyer is like a near future, very grounded, not super, you know, far flung, but definitely,
绝对值得一读。读起来很容易，你知道，在这一类书中，我猜，而且相当短。所以我听说有声书也
definitely worth the read. It's pretty easy read, you know, on a scale of such books, I guess, and reasonably short. So I've heard the audio book is also
非常好。我通常听有声书。我实际上是在Kindle上读的这一本。哦。我不知道有声书是否像传闻中那么好。
really good. I normally listen to audiobooks. I actually read this one on my Kindle. Oh. I don't know if the audiobook is as good as it's correct up to be.
我正在听有声书，有声书。我的意思是，我才刚开始，但声音很好。所以是的，我认为这是一个很好的声音。好吧。为有声书点赞。但是的，大多数人现在可能知道了，因为电影已经上映了。我女儿在电影之后正在读这本书，也玩得很开心。所以我认为，你知道，它是那种书。它们只是不同。它们是同一个故事。它们彼此非常忠实，但它们在内容深度上仍然有很大不同。所以你和你的女儿分享了你的《挽救计划》文学，而我和我的儿子分享了我的“滴水怪”滴水学院。我们俩谁是更好的父亲？
I'm digging the audio book is, the audiobook. I mean, I've only just started, but the voice is fine. So yeah, I think it's a good voice. All right. Shout out for the audio book. But yeah, most people probably know this now because the movie is out. My daughter is reading the book after the movie and having a good time as well. So I don't think, you know, it's one of those. They're just different. They're the same story. It's pretty true to each other, but they're still pretty different in the, you know, depth of content they have. So you shared your Project Hail Mary literature with your daughter and I shared my drip-or school of drip with my son. Which one of us is the better father?
我也给我的孩子们看了那个视频。说明一下。说明一下。有一些粗俗的内容。所以如果你，就像，如果这是你非常关心的事情，请注意。有一些轻微的脏话。绝对有，是的，可能有几个F开头的词之类的。
I showed my kids that video too. Just to be clear. Just to be clear. There is some vulgarity. So if you, like, just be mindful if you, if that's something you're very concerned about. There are a few minor profanities. There's definitely, yeah, there's probably some F bombs and stuff like that.
公平地说，我只给我的12岁孩子看了。所以我认为我不会给6岁的孩子看。先自己看一遍。这就是我们说的。是的，完全同意。绝对。观众，怎么说，建议酌情观看？酷。好吧。是的。如果你读了这本书并从图书馆借阅，而不是花昂贵的电影票钱，你可以转而通过在Patreon上关注我们来把那笔额外的钱给我们。我们非常感谢我们所有的赞助人。所有的钱都存在一个账户里，我们用它来帮助节目。我们尝试让更多人对节目感兴趣，特别是那些刚开始职业生涯的人。
To be fair, I only showed it to my 12-year-old. So I don't think I would show it to a six-year-old. Just watch it first. That's what we're saying. Yeah, totally. Definitely. A viewer, what is it, discretion advised or something? Cool. All right. Yeah. And if you do read the book and get it from the library instead of paying for expensive movie tickets, you could turn around and give that extra money to us by following us on Patreon. We do really appreciate all of our patrons. All the money just sits in an account where we use it to help out the show. We try and get more folks. interested in the show, especially folks who are starting their career.
所以我们所有人集体非常感谢你们的捐赠。好吧，那么工具环节，帕特里克这次要跳过。好吧，帕特里克，这会让你大吃一惊，或者你已经知道了。我想玩《最终幻想6》。就是那个有埃德加、萨宾和蒂娜的。基本上，它在美国实际上是《最终幻想3》，但在日本他们叫它6。我知道这是哪一个。所以它有，你知道，蒂娜和幻兽有联系。
And so all of us collectively really appreciate your donations. Okay, so tool of the show, Patrick's going to skip this time. Okay, Patrick, this is going to blow, either going to blow your mind or you already know about it. I wanted to play Final Fantasy 6. That's the one with Edgar and Sabin and Tara. Basically, it's actually Final Fantasy 3 in the U.S., but they call it six in Japan. I know which one this is. So it's with, you know, Tara has like got a connection with the Asper's.
结果证明，我不会剧透的。但基本上，喜欢这个游戏，喜欢这个故事，大概20年没玩过了。所以我想，超过20年了。所以我想，我想玩它。但就像，我知道我肯定能通关。我的意思是，如果我12岁时能通关，我相信我40岁时也能通关，不管怎样。所以我当时想，我怎么才能玩这个游戏并获得故事和体验，但仍然受到挑战，对吧？好吧。天哪。所以我发现人们制作，你，我一直做，比如，
And it turns out, I'm not going to spoil it. But basically, love the game, love the story, haven't played it in probably 20 years. So I thought, more than 20 years. So I thought, I want to play it. But like, I know I'm just going to beat it. I mean, if I could beat it at 12, I'm sure I could beat it at 40, whatever. So I was like, how can I play this game and get the story and experience, but like still be challenged, right? Okay. Oh, man. So I found out that people make, you, I've always done, like,
用于翻译的ROM修改，所以我可以玩，比如，日本游戏的英文版。但有一个专门的ROM修改社区，只是为了让游戏变得更难或更有趣，或者两者兼有，或者其他什么。所以我玩了，呃，《食人魔之战》，不是《食人魔之战》困难版。呃，有一个《食人魔之战》模组，我可以查一下，但基本上让游戏变得更难，但也平衡了所有单位等等。另外还有一个《食人魔之战》困难版，但那只是非常令人沮丧。
ROM hacks for translation, so I can play, like, English versions of Japanese games. But there's a whole ROM hacking community just for making games either harder or more interesting or both, or what have you. And so I played, uh, ogre battle, it's not Ogre Battle hard type. Uh, There's an ogre battle mod, which I can look up, but basically made the game harder, but also balanced all the units and everything. There's separately an ogre battle hard type, but that was just very frustrating.
就像在某种程度上，我不想做的是玩同样的游戏，但必须刷上100个小时。你知道，那不有趣。我想要的是一种更难的体验，但花费大致相同的时间，你只需要更具战略性，对吧？所以我完成了那个《食人魔之战》模组，然后我发现了这个惊人的《最终幻想6》模组。
Like at some point, what I don't want to do is to play the same game, but have to grind for like 100 hours. You know, like that's not fun. What I want is just like a harder experience, but taking roughly the same amount of time, you just have to be more strategic, right? So I finished that Ogre Battle mod, and then I found this amazing Final Fantasy 6 mod.
它叫T-Edition，它增加了很多疯狂的内容。例如，有成就，有所有这些额外的支线任务。内容非常多。有新的BOSS。实际上有不同的机制。所以例如，你知道，通常在《最终幻想》中，你几乎从不，你几乎从不，比如，
It's called T-Edition, and it adds an insane amount of content. For example, there's achievements, there's like all these extra side quests. There's just a ton of content. There's new bosses. There's actually like a different mechanics. So for example, you know, generally in Final Fantasy, you almost never you almost never like
施放某些法术，就像你知道它们在游戏中是为了连续性，但就像你什么时候真的会给敌人下毒？这很罕见，对吧？但现在就像有不同的BOSS有特定的弱点，这鼓励你使用所有的
cast certain spells like you know they're kind of in the game for continuity but like when do you really ever like poison your enemy it's pretty rare right but but now it's like there's different bosses that have certain weaknesses that kind of encourages you to use the whole
法术组合，太棒了。我的意思是，我玩了一半了，我担心，你知道，当你玩ROM修改时，你知道，总有风险，黑客设计者不像原始游戏设计者那样彻底。而且就像，你可能会玩到40个小时，现在你只是卡住了。就像，你无法取得进展。
gambit of spells phenomenal I mean I'm about halfway through it I was worried that you know when you play a ROM hack you know There's always the risk that the ROM, the hack designer just isn't as thorough as the original game designer. And like, you'll get maybe 40 hours into the game and now you're just stuck. Like, you just can't make progress.
所以你浪费了你的时间。但这个T-Edition非常受欢迎。它有一个繁荣的社区。它存在很久了。成吨的人已经通关了。所以你知道它就像你肯定能玩到最后。但它超级，超级有趣。我一直在手机上玩它，
And so you wasted your time. But this T edition is super popular. It's got a thriving community. It's been around forever. Tons of people have beaten it. And so you know that it's like you're going to get to the end. but it's super, super fun. I've been playing it on my phone,
这太棒了。我从来没玩过《最终幻想》。我总是叫它《最终幻想3》，但我想是6。等等，所以你从来没玩过3？没有，呃-呃。哦，天哪。7。
and it's a blast. I was awesome. I have never played Final Fantasy. I would always call it Final Fantasy 3, but six, I guess. Wait, so you never played 3? No, uh-uh. Oh, man. Seven.
我玩过7，但从没玩过3。看，我实际上在3就停下了，因为我从来没有PlayStation。我错过了。我实际上，我一年前玩了7，但你知道，我的童年错过了7。它值得吗，
I did 7, but never 3. See, I actually stopped at 3 because I never had a PlayStation. I missed out. I actually, I played seven a year ago, but you know, my childhood I missed out on seven. Is it worth like,
我猜，有时当你玩老游戏时，如果你没有怀旧情结，它们真的很难玩，因为生活质量的原因。就像，很多随机的、愚蠢的事情你必须做，
I guess, sometimes when you play the old games, like if you don't have nostalgia, they're really tough to play for like quality of life reasons. Just like, lots of random, stupid stuff you got to do
或者只是，你知道，他们试图让游戏更长。你知道，我不知道类似的事情。就像，这个游戏现在还能玩吗？还是你必须有怀旧情结？
or just like, you know, they tried to make the game longer. You know, I don't know stuff like that. Like, is this game still playable? Or do you got to have nostalgia for it?
或者这会像，不，有更好的游戏可以玩？嗯，这真的很难说。好吧，我会说故事非常棒，即使是第一次玩也可能值得一玩。故事非常，非常棒。我觉得节奏很好。
Or is this going to be like, no, there's better games to play? Um, It's really hard to say. Okay, I would say the story is phenomenal and probably worth playing, even if it's the first time. The story is very, very good. I feel like the pace is good.
我在纠结，如果你直接玩T-Edition，那可能会很困难，因为，你知道，你被期望去，是的，我会玩普通版。好吧。T-Edition真的适合那些想玩第二次的人。但我绝对会回去玩。如果你要玩普通版，有一些安卓移植版或iOS移植版可能比在模拟器上玩更好。
I'm debating whether, if you go straight to T edition, that might be difficult because, you know, you are kind of expected to, Yeah, I would play the regular edition. Okay. The T edition would really be for people who want to play it a second time. But I would definitely go back and play. If you're going to play the regular version, there's some Android ports or iOS ports that are probably better than playing it on emulator.
但我认为这是一个伟大的游戏，非常扎实。我第一次玩它时震惊了，我以为我到了游戏结尾，结果发现你才到了一半。有点像，如果你玩过《塞尔达传说：众神的三角力量》，超级任天堂。是的，记得当，就像，你打败了加农，然后，就像，他把你扔进了黑暗世界，
But I think it's a great game, very solid. It shocked me the first time I played it, where I thought I was at the end of the game, and it turns out you're only at the halfway point. Kind of like, if you ever played a link to the past, Super Nintendo. Yeah, remember when, like, you fight Gannon and then, like, he throws you into the dark world
或者不管他们叫什么，另一个世界？我们必须为30年前的游戏提供剧透警告吗？有点像那样，虽然在那个游戏中，它更明显，因为，就像，很明显世界上不仅仅有三件事要做，对吧？这里不太明显，对吧？我真的以为，好吧，游戏结束了，而我才完成了一半。哦，不错。是的，我为自己感到羞耻。
or whatever they call that, the other world? Do we have to give spoiler alerts for, like, 30-year-old guests? It's kind of like that where, although in that game, it was more obvious because, like, clearly there aren't just three things to do in the whole world, right? Here it's less obvious, right? I literally thought, well, the game's over, and I was only halfway done. Oh, nice. Yeah, I'm ashamed to me.
我也只玩过《时空之轮》的开头。每个人都说它是最棒的RPG，但是的，我不擅长RPG。是的，《时空之轮》非常好。我想，我能看到人们在《时空之轮》中卡住，因为有些部分你必须坚持下去，
I also have only ever made it, like, through the very beginning of Chrono Trigger. Everyone's the most amazing RPG ever, but yeah, I'm bad with RPGs. Yeah, Chrono Trigger was very good. I think the, I could see people getting stuck in Chrono Trigger because there's some parts where you just have to kind of persevere. to make the other parts kind of worth it. I would say Final Fantasy 3, there's constantly something interesting going on.
才能让其他部分变得值得。我会说《最终幻想3》，总是有有趣的事情发生。
All right, all right. Well, I am trying to go back and play more of these. So I'll add it to the list. We'll see if I get to it. You should totally play the ROM hack. It's weird. It says that it doesn't, there's glitches on emulators,
好吧，好吧。嗯，我正在尝试回去玩更多这些游戏。所以我把它加到列表里。看看我能不能玩到它。你应该完全去玩那个ROM修改。很奇怪。它说它没有，模拟器上有故障，
but I think that was back in the past. Just quick, quick history of emulators. So, you know, the machine has its own instruction set. And Patrick probably knows this way better than I do, so I'm going to try my best. You know, it has like, you know, move things over here or this other type of instruction or whatever, like at really low level. And your computer, you know, doesn't have all the same instructions, right?
但我认为那是过去的事了。快速，快速的模拟器历史。所以，你知道，机器有它自己的指令集。帕特里克可能比我更了解这一点，所以我尽力而为。你知道，它有，就像，你知道，把东西移到这里或那种指令或其他什么，就像在非常低的层面。而你的电脑，你知道，没有所有相同的指令，对吧？
Your phone probably has different instructions in your desktop. And so, like, it has sort of translate the instructions from, you know, what it would give a real Nintendo to what it has to give your computer. And back in the day, like, they couldn't just translate. translate it perfectly because it became really expensive. Like there might be an instruction that was super fast on Nintendo, but if you're really slow on your computer. And so when they made these hacks,
你的手机可能和你的桌面有不同的指令。所以，就像，它必须把指令从，你知道，它会给真正的任天堂的东西翻译成它必须给你的电脑的东西。而在过去，就像，他们不能只是翻译。完美地翻译它，因为它变得非常昂贵。就像可能有一个指令在任天堂上超级快，但如果你在你的电脑上非常慢。所以当他们制作这些修改时，
I guess the hacks only worked on the Nintendo without glitches. But now the emulators are like absolutely perfect because the machines are just so fast. So there were these warnings about, oh, if you're playing on emulator, the sound won't work, but everything worked perfectly. I play almost all old games with the sound off because I find the repetitive chip tune thing
我猜这些修改只在任天堂上工作而没有故障。但现在模拟器就像绝对完美，因为机器太快了。所以有这些警告，哦，如果你在模拟器上玩，声音不会工作，但一切都完美运行。我几乎所有老游戏都静音玩，因为我发现重复的芯片音乐
only listenable and very small doses. So I basically play with everything on mute. Yeah, me too actually. Even on my switch. In my case it's because I'm like in the car or I'm in the passenger speed or something where I don't. Thank you for clarification. Yeah.
只有在极小剂量下才可听。所以我基本上所有东西都静音玩。是的，我也是。即使在我的Switch上。在我的情况下，是因为我像在车里，或者我在乘客座位上，或者什么地方，我不。谢谢你的澄清。是的。
I just don't want to bother people usually. Yeah. All right. it is time for the agents to code to the rest of our podcast. Yeah, I mean, why are we even here? Like, can't I just press a button on generate script? Oh, man. I mean, what a crazy time we're living in.
我通常只是不想打扰别人。是的。好吧。是时候让代理商为我们播客的其余部分编码了。是的，我的意思是，我们为什么还要在这里？就像，我不能只是按一个按钮生成脚本吗？哦，天哪。我的意思是，我们生活在一个多么疯狂的时代。
So quick, quick history lesson. You know, Intellicense has been around forever. I don't know if folks remember the word intelligence, but and I don't know how it worked. I mean, I can take a guess. I mean, I guess that, you know, it ingests all of your code on your, on your local computer. And then it, you know, builds up some kind of statistical models.
所以快速，快速的历史课。你知道，Intellisense已经存在很久了。我不知道人们是否还记得Intellisense这个词，而且我不知道它是怎么工作的。我的意思是，我可以猜一下。我的意思是，我猜，你知道，它摄取了你本地电脑上的所有代码。然后它，你知道，建立某种统计模型。
And then when you start typing, you know, or maybe it doesn't even need statistics, maybe it's totally deterministic, but you start typing, you know, my object dot, cac, and it just fills in, you know, cache triangle or something like that because it knows that that function exists and there aren't any other functions that start with CAC and so it'll just pop that up next to your cursor and you could hit tab and it'll just auto complete that function name for you. So that's been around forever
然后当你开始输入时，你知道，或者也许它甚至不需要统计数据，也许它是完全确定性的，但你开始输入，你知道，my object dot, cac，它只是填入，你知道，cache triangle之类的东西，因为它知道那个函数存在，而且没有其他以CAC开头的函数，所以它会把那个弹出来放在你的光标旁边，你可以按Tab键，它就会为你自动完成那个函数名。所以这已经存在很久了，
and that's been great. I had like an Emacs extension at some point a long time ago that did this. So even in the terminal you could do it and everything. that's been around forever. And then, you know, the large language models started to get really good. And so, yeah, there was, they started doing auto-complete on steroids where you could use GitHub copilot and you could start typing, you know, four. And it would just auto-complete, you know, the entire four-loop and the contents of the four-loop or something if it was pretty easy to infer from other parts of the
而且那很棒。我很久以前有一个Emacs扩展程序做过这个。所以即使在终端里你也可以做到，一切。那已经存在很久了。然后，你知道，大语言模型开始变得非常好。所以，是的，有，他们开始在类固醇上进行自动完成，你可以使用GitHub Copilot，你可以开始输入，你知道，for。它就会自动完成，你知道，整个for循环和for循环的内容，或者如果从代码库的其他部分很容易推断出来的话。所以那真的很酷。然后Cursor出来了。所以Cursor有一个很棒的功能，它会在你的光标处自动完成，但然后它会跳来跳去。所以例如，在大多数语言中，你有某种导入。所以在TypeScript中叫import，在Python中叫import，T++中，是pound include，对吧？所以假设作为自动完成的一部分，它最终需要使用一个你还没有导入的库。你可以按Tab键来完成那段代码，然后它会给你一个类似通知的东西，
code based. So that was really cool. And then a cursor came out. And so cursor had this neat feature where it would auto-complete at your starting at your cursor, but then it would jump around. So for example, in most languages, you have some type of import. So in TypeScript is called import, and Python is called import, T++, it's pound include, right? And so let's say as part of the auto-complete, it ended up needing to use a library that you weren't yet importing. You could tab to complete that code, and then it would give you a little notification-type thing
文件中的其他地方还有工作要做。所以你可以再次按Tab键，它会跳到文件顶部并向你展示它想在那里自动完成的内容，然后你可以第三次按Tab键，它也会完成导入。所以，你知道，这种持续到我认为在某个时候Cursor有了多文件，就像你可以一直按Tab键，
that there's more work to do somewhere else in the file. So you could type tab again, and it would jump to the top of the file and show you what it wants to auto-complete over there, and then you could type tab a third time, and it would do the imports as well. And so, you know, this kind of continued to the point where I think at some point cursor had multi-file, like you could just kind of keep hitting tab,
它会在你的代码库中跳来跳去执行各种事情。所以这一切都很棒。所以然后，所以人们在，你知道，使用它。我正在使用它。这非常令人兴奋。然后Claude Code出现了，那是一个巨大的游戏规则改变者。所以这是，你知道，不仅仅是扩展你已经写了一部分的想法，你可以，你知道，用英语要求它用你的代码做点什么，
and it would jump around your code base doing various things. And so this is all great. And so then, so people were, you know, using that. I was using it. It was very exciting. And then Claude Code came around, and that was a huge game. changer. So this is where, you know, instead of just extending, you know, an idea that you had partially written, you could, you know, kind of ask it in English to do something with your code,
它就会去执行它。而且那，那是相当疯狂的。我记得当它刚出来时，我发布，实际上，我在LinkedIn上最受欢迎的帖子基本上是谈论Claude Code有多棒，然后一大堆人抨击我。有一个家伙我永远不会忘记。如果你在外面听我们说话，你是个混蛋。别听我们的了。但这个家伙就像，你应该比这更好。就像做得更好。你知道，就像Claude Code和这些东西是，他称之为“随机鹦鹉”，我后来发现这是LLM的一个常见贬义词。
and it would go off and do it. And that is, was pretty wild. I remember when that first came out, I post, actually, my most popular post on LinkedIn was basically talking about how awesome Claude Cod Code is and a whole bunch of people like ripping on me. This one guy I'll never forget it. If you're out there listening to us, you're a jerk. Stop listening to us. But this one guy was like, you should be better than this. Like do better. You know, like Claude Cod Code and these things are, he called it a stochastic parrot, which I found out later is like a common pejorative for LOMs.
他就像你应该比这更好，你有一个编程播客，你却信任这些随机鹦鹉，并侮辱我的人格和一切，那个家伙是个混蛋，但，但，但，但这篇帖子非常有争议。这是那种，就像，我不是故意这样做的，但它得到了，我想大概一百五十万次浏览，而且绝对有支持者和反对者，嗯，但事后看来我是对的。我早早就告诉每个人这个Claude Code的东西很棒。实际上，我当时说我认为非常有挑衅性的话是，我说，我这辈子没写过一行机器代码。
he's like you should do better than this you have a programming podcast and you're trusting these stochastic parrots and just insulting my character and everything that guy was a jerk but but but uh but it was a very controversial post there's one of these things that like i didn't do it on purpose but it got it got i think like one and a half million views and there's definitely like pro proponents and antagonists um but i was right in hindsight I told everyone early on that this quad code thing is amazing. Actually, what I had said that I think was so provocative was I said, I have not written a single line of machine code in my whole life.
我100%的代码都通过编译器运行。所以我已经不是在写纯代码了。所以如果我开始通过Claude运行我100%的代码，我只是用英语告诉它做什么，它真的没有改变任何东西。这就是我仍然坚持的立场。我的意思是，我一直在使用它。现在，你知道，即使在今天，有时我必须进入代码，我们会谈论所有这些。但总的来说，我来自哪里是我是一个大粉丝。
I run 100% of my code through the compiler. And so I'm already not writing pure code. So if I start running 100% of my code through Claude and I just tell it in English what to do, it's really not changing anything. And that's kind of where I still stand. I mean, I use it constantly. Now, you know, even today, there are times I have to go in the code and we'll talk about all of that. But in general, kind of where I'm coming from is I'm a big fan.
而且我认为我们生活在非常惊人的，非常惊人的时代。所以也许，你知道，稍微扩展一下从那些早期的，就像你解释Cursor在早期是什么样子的，到，你知道，也许像ClaudeCode或Codex或Gemini，你知道，今天的解决方案。我认为我们也看到了很多边缘上的迭代。所以像，它，MCPs，你知道，围绕检索增强图，RAGs，围绕，你知道，基本上，在我看来，这些有点像围绕如何让LLM，它只是下一个token预测，对吧，如何允许它进行工具调用，这是我们在播客中很久很久很久以前谈论过的事情，当时我们说，嘿，这些聊天东西
And I think it's pretty amazing, pretty amazing times we're living in. So maybe to like, you know, expand a little on the switch from those early sort of like you kind of explain how cursor was. in the early days to, you know, maybe what like ClaudeCode or Codex or the Gemini, you know, solutions are today. I think we've also seen a lot of iterations like around the edges. So things like what it, the MCPs, you know, around retrieval augmented graphs, rags around like, you know, basically, in my opinion, these are kind of like around how to let the LLM, which is just next token prediction, right, how to allow it to do tool calling, which is something we talked about in the podcast a long, long, long time ago where we said, hey, these chat things
如果它们能伸出援手进行网络搜索或连接到Wolfram Alpha会很酷，或者好吧，无论如何，事实证明人们已经在研究那个了。我们只是不知道。所以每个人都有同样的好主意。好。但是然后，你知道，所以基本上是如何与工具交互。并且通过，你知道，它是如何工作的，到，你知道，我不会说它今天已经定型了，但到它今天所处的位置，已经有很多迭代了。然后另一个是围绕某种管理上下文窗口，对吧？那个，嘿，你的代码库，你的问题空间，你的对话，有多少可以被容纳？
would be really cool if they could reach out and do web searches or connect to Wolfram Alpha or okay, well, anyways, turns out people are already working on that. We just didn't know. So everybody had the same good idea. Good. But then, you know, so basically how to interact with tools. And there's been a lot of iterations through, you know, how that works to, you know, I don't say it's settled today, but to where it is today. And then the other one is around sort of managing the context window, right? The, hey, how much of your code base, of your problem space, of your conversation, how much of that can be held?
对于上下文，我认为有趣的是模型本身变得更大了。但不是超级明显的事情之一是，即使你会看到像Gemini这样的东西可以处理一百万个token作为上下文，那并不意味着它同样高效，无论是在运行速度方面，还是在质量方面，一百万个token与一万个token。所以很多这些模型在达到那一百万个token时性能会下降。
And for the context, I think it's been interesting that the models themselves have gotten bigger. But one of the things that isn't super obvious is that even if you will see something like Gemini can handle a million tokens as context, that doesn't mean it's as efficient, both in terms of like how fast it runs, but also in how the quality is, a million tokens versus 10,000 tokens. And so a lot of these models have degraded performance as they reach up to those million tokens.
这是反直觉的，因为它不像哈希映射或列表或数组那样只是增长。你会得到一些奇怪的缓存效应，但通常，你知道，它们被很好地理解了。有这些反直觉的机制。所以积极管理加载到上下文中的内容以及像压缩这样的事情是非常重要的。而且我认为这非常有趣，
It is unintuitive because it's not like a hash map or a list or an array that just grows. And you get some weird cash effects, but generally, you know, they're kind of well understood. There's these unintuitive mechanisms. So aggressively managing what's loaded into the context and things like compaction is super important. And I think it's been very interesting
看到，你知道，像获取你的整个代码库，理解如何使用工具在你的代码库中搜索，如何学习像哪些部分要提取和加载并假设。而且我会说它仍然不完美。你仍然看到有时我甚至看到它使用，你知道，像Claude Code这样的工具，它会，我们谈论幻觉。它会产生API调用的幻觉。但它现在在一个循环中。
to see, you know, something like taking your whole code base, understanding how to use tools to search in your code base, how to learn like which pieces to extract and load up and sort of assume. And I will say it's still not perfect. You still see sometimes I see it even using, you know, a tool like cloud code where it'll, we talk about hallucination. It'll hallucinate API calls. But it's in a loop now.
这就是代理部分，它会尝试编译自己并意识到，等等，为什么我调用了，你知道，features.或者，你知道，object.Dot foo。Dot foo不存在。它是dot bar。而且，你知道，它会弄明白。但不管出于什么原因，就像这个，你知道，
That's the agentic part where it'll try to compile itself and realize like, wait, why did I call, you know, features. or, you know, object. Dot foo. Dot foo isn't doesn't exist. It's dot bar. And, you know, it'll figure it out. But for whatever reason, like this, you know,
foo的幻觉，只是假设，你知道，你有一个列表类，因此你有一个insert。也许你没有insert，因为，你知道，某种深奥的原因。所以你仍然在边缘看到，但很多是因为它试图在第一遍中保持上下文，这导致了区域问题。
hallucinating of food, just assumed that, you know, you have a list class, therefore you have an insert. And maybe you don't have an insert because of, you know, some esoteric reason. And so you still see around the edges, but a lot of that is because it's trying to keep the context down in the first pass, which causes zone problems.
如果它加载了你所有的代码库，如果它试图理解所有这些，速度真的可以，你知道，陷入困境。是的。我的意思是，我认为你触及的另一件事，但只是双击它，是模型的实际智能随着你放入更多信息而下降。所以这创造了一个奇怪的陷阱，有人会从一张完全空白的白纸开始，
If it loads up all your code base, if it tries to understand all of this, the speed can can really, you know, get bogged down. Yeah. I mean, the other thing that I think you touched on, but just double click on it is the actual intelligence of the model goes down as you put more information in it. And so this creates a weird trap where someone will start with a completely blank slate
并说，为我建立一个电子商务网站。它可以做到。但很多是基于它从GitHub上查看许多电子商务网站等获得的某种先天知识。所以它会建立一些东西，你会觉得它真的理解了你建立的东西的本质，但很多可能是某种复制，对吧？然后随着上下文的增长，你最终得到了越来越多关于你特定的，你知道，你正在销售的产品的信息，那么它需要保持越来越多
and say, build me a website for e-commerce. And it can do that. but a lot of that is based on its sort of innate knowledge from looking at many e-commerce sites on GitHub and things like that. And so it'll build something and you'll feel like it really understood the nature of what you built, but a lot of it might be kind of copied, right? And then as the context grows and you end up with more and more bespoke information about your particular, you know, product that you're selling, then it needs to keep more and more
然后说，帮我建一个电子商务网站。它确实能做到。但这很大程度上基于它从GitHub等地方查看许多电子商务网站所获得的内在知识。所以它会构建出一些东西，你会觉得它真的理解了你所构建内容的本质，但其中很多可能只是复制粘贴的，对吧？随着上下文的增加，你最终会拥有越来越多关于你所销售产品的定制化信息，那么它就需要保留越来越多的内容。
information in its, you know, short-term memory. And as it does that, the intelligence starts to go down. And so you see this trap. And so it's just something to be aware of that when you're working with bigger projects, shouldn't expect the same level of intelligence that you have, you know, at a smaller scale. But yeah, the loop thing and the tool calling super important. Okay, so we'll explain a little bit how this works under the hood. So in the beginning, it takes your question and the AI can do one of several things, right? It can answer your question just by emitting some text, or it can call a tool.
信息在它的短期记忆中。随着它这样做，智能水平开始下降。所以你会看到这个陷阱。因此，这只是需要注意的一点，即当你处理更大的项目时，不应该期望它能达到你在小规模项目中所拥有的那种智能水平。但确实，循环机制和工具调用非常重要。好的，那么我们将稍微解释一下这在底层是如何工作的。首先，它会接收你的问题，AI 可以做几件事中的一件，对吧？它可以直接通过输出一些文本来回答你的问题，或者它可以调用一个工具。
and there's several tools that it can choose from. And so this technology has been around is older than Claude Code to Patrick's point. So when it's done calling a tool, the tool information is added to the context. So just to back a bit, so if you ask it, you know, what's a distance from here to the moon?
它有几种工具可以选择。所以这项技术已经存在了，正如帕特里克的观点，它比 Claude Code 更古老。因此，当它调用完一个工具后，工具信息会被添加到上下文中。稍微回顾一下，如果你问它，你知道，从这里到月球的距离是多少？
Because I want to slingshot some astronauts, right? So it'll start giving you that answer. But as it's emitting those tokens, it's also using what it said to generate the next token. So it's possible, I mean, it might be hard to make it do this, but it's possible for it to generate half of an answer and then to actually say, wait a minute, stop. I'm heading in the wrong direction and it's a generally different answer. Like mathematically, that's plausible. It might be hard to craft a question that would cause that every time, but it can happen. So similarly, when it calls a tool, the tool output, it's as if it said those tokens.
因为我想用弹弓效应发射一些宇航员，对吧？所以它会开始给你那个答案。但在它输出这些标记（tokens）的同时，它也在使用它刚才所说的内容来生成下一个标记。所以，我是说，虽然可能很难让它这样做，但它确实有可能生成一半的答案，然后突然说，等一下，停。我走错方向了，然后给出一个完全不同的答案。从数学上讲，这是可能的。可能很难设计出一个每次都能导致这种情况的问题，但它确实可能发生。同样地，当它调用一个工具时，工具的输出就好像是它自己说出了那些标记一样。
So in the sense of like it's now part of the context and it's used to generate the next thing that it says. So the model can either answer you or it can call a tool. When a tool comes back, that information is, let's say, part of the context along with your question, then it can call another tool or it can answer you. And whether, you know, however many tools you want to allow it to call and all of that is up to the discretion of the developer, right? But at some point it's done calling tools. It gives you an answer and that's it.
所以从某种意义上说，它现在成为了上下文的一部分，并被用来生成它接下来要说的内容。因此，模型要么回答你，要么调用一个工具。当工具返回结果时，这些信息，比如说，会和你的问题一起成为上下文的一部分，然后它可以调用另一个工具，或者回答你。至于你想允许它调用多少个工具，以及所有这些，都由开发者自行决定，对吧？但在某个时刻，它会停止调用工具。它给你一个答案，然后就结束了。
To the idea with Agenic was, what if a tool was itself like another question? Like, what if we made this recursive? And so there's two basic ways you can make this recursive. One is where the tool call is actually another question that starts a session within a session. Another way is to say, well, a tool call can actually give me back a list of more tools to call. Both of those are implemented in Claude Code. So you might say something like,
Agenic 的想法是，如果一个工具本身就是另一个问题会怎样？比如，如果我们让这个过程递归会怎样？所以你可以通过两种基本方式实现递归。一种是工具调用实际上是另一个问题，它在一个会话中开启了另一个会话。另一种方式是说，嗯，一个工具调用实际上可以返回给我一个需要调用的工具列表。这两种方式都在 Claude Code 中实现了。所以你可能会说类似这样的话：
I want to remove all the lint errors in my code base and it'll come back and say, okay, I'll run a tool call and we'll run the Pyrite and we'll look at the errors that are involved. That might come back with, you know, 10,000 errors. And the model will actually say, okay, you have a ton of errors here. You know, we're not going to just fix this in one diff.
我想删除代码库中的所有 lint 错误，它会回来并说，好的，我将运行一个工具调用，我们将运行 Pyrite，我们会查看涉及的错误。这可能会返回，你知道，一万个错误。而模型实际上会说，好的，你这里有大量的错误。你知道，我们不会只通过一个差异补丁（diff）就解决这个问题。
A diff, by the way, or a patch is also another tool call, but we're not going to fix 10,000 errors in one patch. So I'm going to create a bunch of subtasks. And those subtasks are like isolated questions that I'm going to ask myself. So the model will ask itself, like in another process or another context, you know, fix all the lint errors where the capitalization is wrong in the very just focus on that. So now the model is really like the initial model is now an orchestrator that's orchestrating
顺便说一下，差异补丁或补丁也是另一个工具调用，但我们不会在一个补丁中修复一万个错误。所以我将创建一堆子任务。这些子任务就像是我要问自己的孤立问题。所以模型会问自己，比如在另一个进程或另一个上下文中，你知道，修复所有大小写错误的地方，只专注于那个。所以现在模型真的就像，最初的模型现在是一个编排者，正在编排
all these sub-questions. And the thing Patrick was saying is, you know, the nice thing is if anything is wrong, that's okay because the expectation is to be eventually correct. So the model, you know, as long as it has a way to verify, it can come back and try to compile to code and say, oh, I made a mistake. I'm going to call another tool call to fix it, et cetera, et cetera. And this continues until there's some kind of stopping criteria, which again is created by the developers. At that point, the model hands the reins back over to you. There's a lot of, I think, maybe unintuitive to outsider like interplay, as you're describing,
所有这些子问题。帕特里克刚才说的是，你知道，好的一点是，如果有什么地方出错了，那也没关系，因为预期的结果是最终正确。所以模型，你知道，只要它有一种验证方法，它就可以回来并尝试编译代码，然后说，哦，我犯了一个错误。我要调用另一个工具来修复它，等等，等等。这种情况会一直持续，直到出现某种停止标准，这同样是由开发者创建的。在那一点上，模型将控制权交还给你。我认为，对于局外人来说，这里有很多可能不直观的相互作用，正如你所描述的，
between what you, when we talked about fine-tuning before, but targeting these coding benchmarks and coding applications and code as like a way of doing sort of long-term planning, which has been something difficult for LLMs to do. But also the interplay between the harness of cloud code and like or, you know, codex or any of them and the underlying model, right? How do you tell it what tool calls to use? You have like a tool call language or do you just let it use a command line? Do you use MCPs, right?
在我们之前谈论微调时，针对这些编码基准测试和编码应用，以及将代码作为一种进行长期规划的方式，这对于大语言模型（LLM）来说一直是一件困难的事情。但同时，Claude Code 的工具框架（harness）与底层模型之间的相互作用也是如此，对吧？你如何告诉它使用哪些工具调用？你有一个工具调用语言，还是直接让它使用命令行？你使用 MCP 吗，对吧？
Like internal for stuff. how do you sort of like craft the system prompt? How do you craft like the each turn, right? Like how far to let the model think before the night? Like there's this interplay between how the model was trained and how you prompt it, guide it, harness it, skeletonize it structure and even ask separate questions about like, hey, how do I, like, how would I plan to do this or how do I decompose this task? So how do you decide, you know, whether to kind of have it do more of a one shot,
比如内部的东西。你如何构建系统提示词？你如何构建每一轮对话，对吧？比如在夜间之前让模型思考到什么程度？模型是如何被训练的，以及你如何提示它、引导它、利用它、骨架化它的结构，甚至提出单独的问题，比如，嘿，我该如何计划做这件事，或者我该如何分解这个任务？所以你如何决定，你知道，是让它更多地进行一次性（one-shot）处理，
like here's what I'm trying to do, just do it. and then saying, let me first ask for to decompose it into tasks. Then I'm going to say for the first task, like output the task as JSON. And then for each thing in the JSON array, prompt it again, right? Like you get all this interplay between how you invoke the LLM and how the LLM works. And then we, I don't think we've yet seen, to be honest, you know, we might talk about in a future episode, but things like OpenClaar or like the various more like computer use things, which is the LLM is really starting to train on this use case, right?
比如这就是我想要做的，直接去做。然后说，让我先要求它将其分解为任务。然后我会说对于第一个任务，比如将任务输出为 JSON。然后对于 JSON 数组中的每一项，再次提示它，对吧？你得到了所有这些关于你如何调用 LLM 以及 LLM 如何工作的相互作用。老实说，我不认为我们已经看到了，你知道，我们可能会在未来的剧集中讨论，但像 OpenClaar 或各种更像计算机使用（computer use）的东西，也就是 LLM 真正开始针对这个用例进行训练，对吧？
Sort of actually getting to where they themselves are, you know, making sure that during training, they are understanding and working with this tooling better. And so for now, it's a lot of, I don't want to say hackery. That's not the right word, but like a lot of sort of humans iterating or having LLMs iterate the LLM harness for the LLM. Oh my gosh, it's just LLM. But, you know, I think there's a lot of nuance.
某种程度上真正达到了它们自己，你知道，确保在训练期间，它们能更好地理解和使用这些工具。所以目前，这更多的是，我不想说这是黑客行为。那不是正确的词，但更像是人类在迭代，或者让 LLM 迭代 LLM 的工具框架。天哪，这全是 LLM。但是，你知道，我认为这里面有很多细微差别。
And you'll see people talk about how Codex works, how, you know, cloud code works, how the Gemini I think, but there's also like open code, right, which is a version of quad code, but with open source and, you know, bring your own back end as a more like supported sort of methodology.
你会看到人们谈论 Codex 是如何工作的，你知道，Claude Code 是如何工作的，Gemini 我想也是，但还有像 OpenCode，对吧，它是 Claude Code 的一个版本，但是开源的，而且，你知道，自带后端（bring your own back end）是一种更受支持的方法论。
And I think all of them have nuanced difference. In fact, just last week Claude code had its source code leaked. And people were kind of deep diving and seeing oh, hey, there's like, you know, monitoring of how upset the user is. There's like all this stuff in it you kind of wouldn't assume. So I don't think there's a
我认为它们都有细微的差别。事实上，就在上周，Claude Code 的源代码泄露了。人们在深入研究并发现，哦，嘿，这里有，你知道，对用户有多沮丧的监控。里面有所有这些你可能不会假设的东西。所以我认为还没有一个
settled out harness approach yet. And then the question is like, how much does the harness need to match the individual model is, is unclear because every model is sort of slightly different too. Yeah. Yeah, great points. Yeah, I think it's still pretty early days. One sort of thing that really surprised me is how well it works on things that aren't even coding related. you know, there's recently Google released a set of skills. So we didn't really talk about this,
定型的工具框架方法。然后问题是，工具框架需要与单个模型匹配到什么程度，这还不清楚，因为每个模型在某种程度上也略有不同。是的。是的，很好的观点。是的，我认为现在还处于早期阶段。有一件事让我非常惊讶，那就是它在甚至与编码无关的事情上也工作得很好。你知道，最近谷歌发布了一套技能。所以我们并没有真正谈论这个，
but a skill is basically a set of tools with really detailed prompts behind each of the tools. So, you know, there might be a skill where it's about reading and writing Google Docs. And so you'll get a set of tools that let you sort of do the mechanics, you know, add to a Google Doc, read a Google Doc, insert characters into a dock, etc. But then you'll also get this really detailed markdown of what is the true sort of platonic nature. What is the nature of a Google Doc? Like what actually is it? And yeah, and so you can you can plug that Google G Suite skill into, or I think they're calling a Google workspace skill.
但技能基本上是一组工具，每个工具背后都有非常详细的提示词。所以，你知道，可能有一种关于阅读和编写 Google Docs 的技能。所以你会得到一套工具，让你能够进行机械操作，你知道，添加到 Google Doc，读取 Google Doc，在文档中插入字符等等。但你也会得到这个非常详细的 Markdown，说明什么是真正的柏拉图式的本质。Google Doc 的本质是什么？它到底是什么？是的，所以你可以将那个 Google G Suite 技能插入到，或者我想他们称之为 Google Workspace 技能，
into any of these coding agents and then they have that power. So I think that this is going to be pretty disruptive to a lot of industries. I'm thinking like finance, medical, legal, et cetera, in the same way that it's disruptive to coding. It's a very generic system.
插入到任何这些编码代理中，然后它们就拥有了那种能力。所以我认为这对许多行业来说将是相当具有颠覆性的。我想到的是金融、医疗、法律等等，就像它对编码具有颠覆性一样。这是一个非常通用的系统。
So the way that, you know, ClaudeCode work that's pretty different from any of its predecessors was that the tools that it had were extremely generic. You know, people were at the time building very specific tools. Like, here's a tool to access, you know, my bespoke database. But I'm not going to give you just open SQL access because you might just drop all the tables in my database. So I'm going to give you like this tool adds a customer record and this tool deletes a customer record, like very, very specific tools.
所以，你知道，Claude Code 的工作方式与它的任何前身都非常不同，因为它拥有的工具极其通用。你知道，当时人们正在构建非常具体的工具。比如，这是一个访问，你知道，我的定制数据库的工具。但我不会只给你开放 SQL 访问权限，因为你可能会直接删除我数据库中的所有表。所以我给你像这个工具添加客户记录，这个工具删除客户记录，非常非常具体的工具。
And Cloud Code came around and said, well, we're going to give you a tool call. bash, which can do anything. And we're going to give you a tool called patch that can just patch any file anywhere and a read file tool and read a chunk of a file tool, etc. But just super, super generic. And in the beginning, it's kind of scary, right? And so that's why by default, most of the tools kind of ask for your permission if you're going to patch a file, etc. But then over time, I feel people have just gotten more and more comfortable where I think most people probably run with like a workspace yolo kind of mode where, hey, as long as you're in my code base, you can read and write whatever you want. And you don't have to prompt me all the time. And so people are getting more comfortable with it.
而 Claude Code 出现后说，好吧，我们要给你一个名为 bash 的工具调用，它可以做任何事情。我们要给你一个名为 patch 的工具，它可以修补任何地方的任何文件，还有一个读取文件工具和一个读取文件块的工具等等。但就是超级超级通用。起初，这有点吓人，对吧？所以这就是为什么默认情况下，大多数工具在你要修补文件时都会请求你的许可，等等。但随着时间的推移，我觉得人们已经变得越来越习惯了，我认为大多数人可能以一种“工作区 YOLO”模式运行，即，嘿，只要你在我的代码库中，你想读写什么都可以。你不需要一直提示我。所以人们正变得越来越习惯它。
I was using it recently to create notes where basically I wanted a midterm kind of help guide for my students. And so I said, hey, you know, here's the textbook and here's the midterm, you know, come up with sort of a help guide. And kind of what Patrick was saying in the beginning, the help guide was okay, but, you know, not great. and I realized I was kind of asking it to do a lot. You know, it's a big textbook. It's a big midterm. And I said, hey, break the textbook up in a chapters and give me a study guide for each chapter.
我最近在用它做笔记，基本上我想为我的学生制作一个期中考试的辅助指南。所以我说，嘿，你知道，这是教科书，这是期中考试，你知道，想出一个辅助指南。就像帕特里克在开始时所说的那样，辅助指南还可以，但是，你知道，不太好。我意识到我让它做的事情太多了。你知道，这是一本大教科书。这是一个大的期中考试。我说，嘿，把教科书分成章节，给我每一章的学习指南。
And that kind of forced it to, you know, use many tasks and each task having only to read a chapter, you know, as we talked about, the model gets dumber if you give it more information. So because each subtask only had to think about a chapter, I actually got a much better summary just from changing the prompt. Yeah, I mean, I guess that's like a good transition into our next thing, like a set of maybe like learnings
这迫使它，你知道，使用多个任务，每个任务只需要阅读一章，你知道，正如我们所讨论的，如果你给模型提供更多信息，它会变得更笨。所以因为每个子任务只需要考虑一章，我实际上仅仅通过改变提示词就得到了一个好得多的总结。是的，我的意思是，这就像是我们下一件事的一个很好的过渡，比如一些学习
guidelines. I do agree with like general use and the bright future. But I mean, I guess like the first one and we kind of talked about this with like hallucinating with like needing to break down, you know, sort of plans we're going to talk about somebody's a minute, is at least if you're working in code, but even if you're not, like even if you're working,
指南。我确实同意像通用使用和光明的未来。但我的意思是，我想第一个，我们已经谈到了像幻觉，像需要分解，你知道，我们要谈论的计划，至少如果你在代码中工作，即使你不在，比如即使你在工作，
I've been playing around, maybe we'll talk about a future episode, but like using a lot of markdown files and something like obsidian to track stuff and to track thinking and doing basic file manipulation. But use Git. Even if you're not going to push it up to GitHub, it doesn't matter. And I will say like a lot of these tools have skills needily to do like Gitwork trees, which I will not lie. I have never used a Gitwork tree in my life.
我一直在尝试，也许我们会在未来的剧集中讨论，但比如使用大量的 Markdown 文件和像 Obsidian 这样的东西来跟踪事情，跟踪思考，并进行基本的文件操作。但要使用 Git。即使你不打算把它推送到 GitHub，也没关系。而且我会说，很多这些工具都有技能需要做像 Git 工作树（worktrees）这样的事情，我不会撒谎。我这辈子从来没用过 Git 工作树。
I don't know how it works. I don't know how it works either. Okay, good. I'm not the only book, but like sophisticated ways of using Git, they know how to do it. You just have to tell them you want it done, right? And then anytime it's sort of like working, check it in. If you make a change, check it in it.
我不知道它是怎么工作的。我也不知道。好的，很好。我不是唯一一个，但像使用 Git 的复杂方式，它们知道怎么做。你只需要告诉它们你想完成它，对吧？然后任何时候它在工作，就提交它。如果你做了更改，就提交它。
Like you can always go back and then you can always tell the alum, like, if you want to try rolling forward, which we'll talk about in a future tip, you can say things like, hey, like this last change didn't work, right? And then it will be like, oh, okay, yeah, like let me revert it or let me, you know, look at the diff, right? And so it has access. So Git is like something we talk about, kind of, you know, basic, technical person,
就像你总是可以回去，然后你总是可以告诉 LLM，比如，如果你想尝试向前滚动，我们会在未来的提示中讨论，你可以说，嘿，这最后一次更改没起作用，对吧？然后它会说，哦，好的，是的，让我撤销它，或者让我，你知道，查看差异，对吧？所以它有访问权限。所以 Git 就像我们谈论的，某种，你知道，基本的，技术人员，
software engineer skill, but definitely here. And again, I use this for personal workflows without any remote repository. It's just a local thing. It doesn't matter. It's just to have like a history
软件工程师技能，但在这里绝对是。而且再说一次，我将它用于个人工作流，没有任何远程仓库。它只是一个本地的东西。没关系。它只是为了拥有像历史记录一样
that is like archived of my instructions of, you know, what I was doing, of my code. Yeah, the agent is amazing at writing detailed Git COVID messages too. So you just tell, But hey, do a Git commit here of all the untracked files and with a nice message. And if you do that in your like session, it will often include notes from the session,
存档的我的指令，你知道，我在做什么，我的代码。是的，代理在编写详细的 Git 提交信息方面也很棒。所以你只需要告诉它，嘿，在这里对所有未跟踪的文件做一个 Git 提交，并附上一条好的信息。如果你在你的会话中这样做，它通常会包含来自会话的笔记，
like things you were trying to do that wouldn't necessarily be inferrable from the code. And then I guess that'll go to my next thing is before you start, you know, attempting. I guess like the term is sort of broadly vibe coding where like to Jason's what you try not to actually write code. although that term is, I think, a little derogatory, but like whatever. And people, we can talk about the ethics or morality of it some other time, but, you know, it just is here. So, okay. But I think there's like the similar term as one shotting, which is like, hey, make me a website and you're just like let it go.
比如你试图做的事情，这些事情不一定能从代码中推断出来。然后我想这会引出我的下一件事，在你开始，你知道，尝试之前。我想这个术语大致是“氛围编码”（vibe coding），就像 Jason 说的，你尽量不去真正写代码。虽然那个术语，我认为，有点贬义，但随便吧。人们，我们可以在其他时间谈论它的伦理或道德，但是，你知道，它就在这里。所以，好的。但我认为有一个类似的术语叫“一次性”（one-shotting），就是，嘿，给我做一个网站，然后你就让它去做了。
You don't do any. That may be a way. I don't know that it works amazingly today. But what I will say is all the tools I use have like a planning, you know, sort of flow. And in the planning flow, the tool is not writing anything to disk. It's not making any changes. It is simply attempting to break down your request into what it's going to do to actually go ahead and extract most of the needed context.
你什么都不做。那可能是一种方式。我不知道它今天是否工作得非常好。但我会说，我使用的所有工具都有一个规划，你知道，某种流程。在规划流程中，工具不会向磁盘写入任何东西。它不会做任何更改。它只是试图将你的请求分解为它将要做的事情，以实际继续并提取大部分所需的上下文。
And it used to be that it was just telling it like think harder and like make a task list. And then it would go to the task list. More recently, I've seen the tools get better. And basically what they'll do is, you know, hey, I want to add this feature. I want to build this thing. It will go like do the research, put snippets of code. And then you can review it of varying links
过去它只是告诉它像“思考得更努力”并“列出任务清单”。然后它会去执行任务清单。最近，我看到工具变得更好了。基本上它们会做的是，你知道，嘿，我想添加这个功能。我想构建这个东西。它会去进行研究，放入代码片段。然后你可以查看不同长度的它，
and spend time going two, three, four times. The better you get that, the better like the output will be. And you can ask questions like, why did you do that? If it's in a domain you don't know about or like just force it to reconsider.
并花时间进行两、三次、四次。你做得越好，输出就会越好。你可以问一些问题，比如，你为什么要那样做？如果它是在你不知道的领域，或者只是强迫它重新考虑。
Like, is this the only option? There's like lots of things you can do and there's skills that will also help to. Although sometimes those skills go out of date as the harnesses roll forward in terms of like, do you need to do those extra steps or not. But then once you sort of get through the planning, a lot of them will then clear the context and keep only the like,
比如，这是唯一的选择吗？有很多事情你可以做，也有一些技能可以提供帮助。虽然有时这些技能会随着工具框架的向前推进而过时，比如，你是否需要做那些额外的步骤。但一旦你完成了规划，很多工具就会清除上下文，只保留像，
I have minimized the description of the work to be done, including function calls, pertinent snippets and all of that. And what you'll find is the execution runs much faster and is less likely to run out of context while doing the thing you described in your planning. Yeah. So we should talk about running out of context.
我已经最小化了要完成的工作描述，包括函数调用、相关的片段和所有这些。你会发现执行运行得更快，并且在做你在规划中描述的事情时不太可能耗尽上下文。是的。所以我们应该谈谈耗尽上下文。
So, as we talked about earlier, your model has a context window, which means the model can only take in so many tokens at a time. It's not a recurrent model, so it doesn't sort of accumulate anything. And so every time it reads in a question or a tool call result, it reads in the entire context and then makes a decision. And so because of that, the context has to have a limit. When the model hits the limit or gets close to it, it does what's called compacting, and it sucks. And as of today, it hasn't really gotten much better. So basically, the way compacting works is pretty simple.
所以，正如我们之前讨论的，你的模型有一个上下文窗口，这意味着模型一次只能接收这么多标记。它不是一个循环模型，所以它不会积累任何东西。因此，每次它读取一个问题或一个工具调用结果时，它都会读取整个上下文，然后做出决定。因此，上下文必须有一个限制。当模型达到限制或接近它时，它会做所谓的压缩（compacting），而且这很糟糕。截至今天，它并没有真正变得好多少。所以基本上，压缩的工作方式很简单。
The context is made up of a list of messages. So a message might be something you asked it. A message could be part of its response because now you have this multi question answer session, right? A message could also be a result from a tool. A message could be a request to call a tool. These are all messages, this whole ledger of things that have happened, right? And so in compaction, you know, it's going to preserve some of the things that are really important. So when you told it something and it responded,
上下文由一系列消息组成。所以一条消息可能是你问它的东西。一条消息可能是它响应的一部分，因为现在你有了这个多问答会话，对吧？一条消息也可能是来自工具的结果。一条消息可能是调用工具的请求。这些都是消息，整个已经发生的事情的分类账，对吧？所以在压缩中，你知道，它会保留一些真正重要的东西。所以当你告诉它某事并且它响应时，
there's probably enough important information in it. Those will get kept in their entirety. But when a tool responds with like an entire PDF and it read the whole thing, it's going to try to summarize that. So it's going to summarize that whole PDF, you know, down to maybe a paragraph or two. And so compaction is all about sort of summarization. and then continue to summarize until you have 90% of your context window open again.
里面可能有足够重要的信息。那些会被完整保留。但当一个工具用像整个 PDF 这样的东西响应，并且它阅读了整个内容时，它会尝试总结它。所以它会总结整个 PDF，你知道，缩减到可能一两段。所以压缩就是关于某种总结。然后继续总结，直到你有 90% 的上下文窗口再次打开。
The problem with the summarization is that details often really matter. And so when you compact, often you're in this really weird state. I've seen situations where I ask a question, it compacts, and then it actually answers like the previous question I asked again. Um, that's just probably maybe a bug. I don't even know. Um, but there's, there's weirdness. So you, you really want to avoid compaction and you, task decomposition is the best way to do it.
总结的问题在于细节往往真的很重要。所以当你压缩时，通常你处于这种非常奇怪的状态。我见过这种情况，我问一个问题，它压缩，然后它实际上回答了我之前问的那个问题。嗯，那可能只是一个错误。我甚至不知道。嗯，但这里有奇怪的地方。所以你，你真的想避免压缩，而你，任务分解是避免它的最好方法。
Yes. Uh, there's another, uh, a point or notes, but yes, you know, decomposition is a skill that I think both like for the purposes of what we're talking about, like getting the mind of, but also more generally, just like separation of concerns, like object oriented things like things, like things, do not go out the window, but in a time when the LLM, I will say currently tends to generate a lot of spaghetti code. It's not pure spaghetti code, but it also doesn't spend cycles is the wrong way to reason about, like it's not true, but whatever.
是的。嗯，还有另一个，嗯，一个点或笔记，但是是的，你知道，分解是一种我认为既是为了我们正在谈论的目的，也是更广泛地说，就像关注点分离，像面向对象的东西，像东西，像东西，不会被抛弃，但在一个 LLM，我会说目前倾向于生成大量意大利面条式代码的时候。它不是纯粹的意大利面条式代码，但它也不会花费周期，这是关于推理的错误方式，就像它不是真的，但随便吧。
It doesn't spend tokens trying to think through like, you know, finding duplicate. It just is happy to copy and paste stuff, right, and not think like, oh, I should move this out to a common predecessor function or a pre-pro. like you'll a lot of that stuff won't happen it will also happily do super inefficient things and the more things for a unit i don't like it is trying to do the worse that becomes so really letting it be step by step even more than maybe it's step by step is is very important yeah totally um kind of related to this there's now the file is a little different it hasn't standardized yet but For most of these, the file is called
它不会花费标记来思考，你知道，寻找重复。它只是很高兴地复制和粘贴东西，对吧，而不去想，哦，我应该把这个移到一个公共的前身函数或预处理中。比如你会，很多那种东西不会发生，它也会很高兴地做超级低效的事情，而且它试图做的单元越多，情况就越糟。所以真正让它一步一步来，甚至比它的一步一步更重要，是非常重要的。是的，完全同意。嗯，有点相关，现在文件有点不同，它还没有标准化，但对于大多数这些，文件被称为
Agents.MD, and agents has to be all caps. This is like a magic file. So whenever you start Claude Code in a directory, it's going to look for an agents. dot MD file, and it's actually going to
Agents.MD，而且 agents 必须全部大写。这是一个魔法文件。所以每当你在一个目录中启动 Claude Code 时，它都会寻找一个 agents.md 文件，并且它实际上会
recurse back through the file tree and look for all of them and add them all up. So here's where you can put things like anytime you change the code. You should, significant change of the code. You should run unit tests and here's how you run them. Or don't use the system version of Python because we have a virtual environment, use the virtual environment Python. These are all instructions that you put in your agent's ID file and that way you don't have to say it every single time you have a question. So think of
递归回文件树并寻找所有这些文件并将它们全部加起来。所以在这里你可以放一些东西，比如任何时候你更改代码。你应该，重大的代码更改。你应该运行单元测试，这是你运行它们的方法。或者不要使用系统版本的 Python，因为我们有一个虚拟环境，使用虚拟环境的 Python。这些都是你放在 agents.md 文件中的指令，这样你就不必每次有问题时都说一遍。所以想想
whatever you put there as being sort of prepended to any question that you could ask. And that's been extremely important. You know, if you want to have a code that doesn't have all sorts of lint errors and just, you know, really kind of cruddy design, then that's where you kind of enforce all of that. Over time, I've been making this more and more complicated. I have one now where, you know, if a file gets too big, it breaks it up and it's sort of instructed to, you know, break the file up semantically, group the file, the code, semantically.
你放在那里的任何东西都像是被预置到你可能问的任何问题之前。这非常重要。你知道，如果你想拥有一个没有各种 lint 错误和只是，你知道，真的很糟糕的设计的代码，那么这就是你强制执行所有这些的地方。随着时间的推移，我一直在让这个变得越来越复杂。我现在有一个，你知道，如果一个文件变得太大，它会把它拆分，并且它被指示，你知道，在语义上拆分文件，对代码进行语义分组。
Originally, I said, hey, if a file gets too big, break it up. And I was ending up with like, cube underscore part 1.5, cube underscore part 2. Dot pie. So then I had to go and add, you know, no, okay,
最初，我说，嘿，如果一个文件变得太大，把它拆分。我最终得到了像 cube_part1.5, cube_part2.py 这样的东西。所以我不得不去添加，你知道，不，好的，
when you break it up, it has to be semantically. It has to be meaning behind each of the file names. So these are all the kind of things you'll do as you're iterating through. But, you know, you can end up with something that granted is going to burn more tokens, but it kind of keeps a healthy,
当你拆分它时，它必须是语义上的。每个文件名背后都必须有意义。所以这些都是你在迭代过程中会做的所有事情。但是，你知道，你最终可能会得到一个，虽然它会消耗更多的标记，但它保持了一个健康的
ecosystem so that if you do end up having to go back and look at that code, you could do it. I had an issue recently where there was a config parameter. I wanted to configure the size of the output video. And so I said, hey, the size of the output video is too small, add a parameter, and by default, make it eight, so that the video is eight times as large. So it's like, sure, done. And I do a run and the video is the same size. So I said, hey, you know, the video is, you know, is only this many pixels by this many.
生态系统，这样如果你最终不得不回去查看那个代码，你可以做到。我最近遇到了一个问题，有一个配置参数。我想配置输出视频的大小。所以我说，嘿，输出视频的大小太小了，添加一个参数，默认情况下，把它设为 8，这样视频就是原来的 8 倍大。所以它就像，当然，完成了。我运行了一下，视频还是同样的大小。所以我说，嘿，你知道，视频是，你知道，只有这么多像素乘这么多。
It should have been bigger. And it was actually argue it to me. It was like, well, you know, the domain might have gotten smaller. And so I actually made the video bigger, but it was now smaller. And so it canceled out. I was like, well, wait a minute, wait a minute, run all the, you know, lint tests and everything. and then come back. And it's like, oh, yeah, I didn't pass this variable through and blah, blah, blah.
它本应该更大的。它实际上在跟我争论。它就像，嗯，你知道，域可能变小了。所以我实际上把视频变大了，但它现在变小了。所以它抵消了。我说，好吧，等一下，等一下，运行所有，你知道，lint 测试和所有东西。然后回来。它就像，哦，是的，我没有传递这个变量，等等等等。
So, like, having good code hygiene is important even for the AI. And so even if you're doing a side project, just keep around an agents.md file and dump it into every project you do so that your AI will have good code hygiene. Otherwise, it will make mistakes just like a person. I think maybe one day this will be different. But just like your analogy earlier where we pass all our code through a compiler, and maybe now we pass all of our instructions through, you know, an agent to code all of our stuff, I do think some classic debugging stuff is kind of like just like those skills that people have learned. And I don't know, it'll be tougher to learn them in the future, perhaps.
所以，拥有良好的代码卫生对于 AI 来说也很重要。所以即使你在做一个副项目，也要保留一个 agents.md 文件并把它扔进你做的每个项目中，这样你的 AI 就会有良好的代码卫生。否则，它会像人一样犯错。我想也许有一天这会不同。但就像你之前的类比，我们把所有的代码都通过编译器，也许现在我们把所有的指令都通过，你知道，一个代理来编码我们所有的东西，我确实认为一些经典的调试东西有点像那些人们已经学到的技能。而且我不知道，未来可能更难学习它们。
But I feel like are still like how you're saying, when you see a problem, it's like, well, how do I get you to agree with me? Why does that come? That comes because you were a manager and you've had to argue with, you know, individual contributors under you. before. Like, why don't you write a test, right? If you just don't go look for the bug, there's going to be like, I didn't see one. Like, did you really try? Like, let's write a test. Write a test. Change the, oh, oh, yeah, yeah, you're right. Okay. You know, like, those skills are still, you know, understanding where the most likely source of problems are,
但我感觉仍然像你说的，当你看到一个问题时，就像，好吧，我怎么让你同意我？为什么会这样？这来自于你曾经是一名经理，并且你曾经不得不与你手下的个人贡献者争论。之前。比如，你为什么不写一个测试，对吧？如果你只是不去寻找错误，就会有，我没看到一个。比如，你真的尝试了吗？比如，让我们写一个测试。写一个测试。改变，哦，哦，是的，是的，你是对的。好的。你知道，那些技能仍然是，你知道，理解问题的最可能来源是什么，
especially in your domain and in your experience, right? Like, I feel, at least for the time being, are going to continue to be, you know, sort of very useful. And then also, there's different ways of building a system, but certain ones sort of stacked together nicely. And so can we can like the LLM training ever really be equally good across like all the different ways of developing, right? Like imagine one person wants to develop in an agile way and one person in a water flow
特别是在你的领域和你的经验中，对吧？比如，我感觉，至少目前为止，将继续是，你知道，非常有用的。然后还有，构建系统有不同的方式，但某些方式堆叠在一起很好。所以 LLM 训练真的能跨越所有不同的开发方式同样好吗，对吧？比如想象一个人想以敏捷方式开发，一个人以瀑布流
method and one per like, is it really going to be equally good at all? It feels unlikely. And so depending on what, but you may still want to stick in your lane or your company has policy or whatever. right? Like, it's very interesting. If it's just like, your code sucks, I rewrote all of it. Well, hang on. How am I going to like get buy off for that? Like, how am I going to get acceptance testing? Right. You know, this is all very difficult, difficult questions. It does lead to your, you know, sort of debugging example.
方法，一个人，它真的会同样好吗？感觉不太可能。所以取决于什么，但你可能仍然想留在你的车道上，或者你的公司有政策等等。对吧？比如，这非常有趣。如果它只是，你的代码很烂，我重写了所有代码。好吧，等一下。我怎么能得到那个的认可？比如，我怎么能得到验收测试？对吧。你知道，这些都是非常困难，困难的问题。它确实引出了你的，你知道，调试示例。
One of the things that I hear a lot of back and forth, I try a little bit of both, but it's just something to be aware of. on different levels, there's like rolling forward with the issue and then just restarting. And that restart can be, like we talked about, reverting to an earlier Git commit. It can be which some tools support better than others. It can be clearing your session or closing it out and starting it again, which erases your history, basically, unless you know, force resume it. Because sometimes something in the context window is tripping it up or polluting it, and it's just stuck in some weird loop.
我经常听到很多来回讨论的一件事，我两种都尝试一点，但这只是需要注意的一点。在不同层面上，有像带着问题向前滚动，然后只是重启。而那个重启可以是，就像我们谈到的，恢复到早期的 Git 提交。它可以是某些工具比其他工具支持得更好的。它可以是清除你的会话或关闭它并重新开始，这基本上会擦除你的历史记录，除非你知道，强制恢复它。因为有时上下文窗口中的某些东西正在绊倒它或污染它，而它只是卡在某种奇怪的循环中。
And literally just exiting and starting again sounds stupid. and asking the same question. Now, we haven't talked about it. It is still kind of slow. Like, it sucks. Like, it generally takes a long time, even if you're asking a simple question, which is not how it is with humans.
而字面上只是退出并重新开始听起来很蠢。并问同样的问题。现在，我们还没有谈论它。它仍然有点慢。比如，它很烂。比如，它通常需要很长时间，即使你问一个简单的问题，这与人类的情况不同。
Like, if you were just having a debate with a human, like, you know, you ask them something simple, they're going to respond very quickly. But you do need to be aware of the difference between sort of adjusting your questions, trying to fix bugs, and just, like, nuking it and starting back and saying, like, let's try this again,
比如，如果你只是在和一个人类辩论，比如，你知道，你问他们一些简单的事情，他们会很快回应。但你确实需要意识到调整你的问题、尝试修复错误，以及只是，像，核平它并重新开始，说，比如，让我们再试一次，
but I'm going to state it a little. different and being aware that even if you copy and pasted the same prompt, you're not actually going to get the same answer because there is randomness in the LLM that's inserted on purpose through things like temperature and other things. So I don't, I haven't tested it, but I would not be, so I would assume that if you paste in the same question twice from the same base state, you aren't guaranteed to get the same answer. Oh, totally. Okay. I'm like not crazy. I know that's true in the chatbots, but I haven't tried it in cloud code or codex or anything. Even if you set the temperature to zero and you fix the random seed and all of that,
但我会陈述得稍微不同一点，并意识到即使你复制并粘贴了相同的提示词，你实际上也不会得到相同的答案，因为 LLM 中存在通过温度和其他东西等事物故意插入的随机性。所以我没有，我没有测试过它，但我不会，所以我假设如果你从相同的基本状态两次粘贴相同的问题，你不能保证得到相同的答案。哦，完全同意。好的。我感觉我没疯。我知道在聊天机器人中这是真的，但我还没有在 Claude Code 或 Codex 或任何东西中尝试过。即使你把温度设置为零，你固定了随机种子和所有这些，
you're still not going to get a deterministic answer because your question is batched with other people's question. And the low-level Kuda operators will give slightly different answers depending on what data is around you. And so, so yeah, there's no way, zero way you can guarantee the turbanism. Ah, Tay, I learned. Yeah, unless you're running on your own hardware with a batch size of one in a very efficient way. And you're waiting a day for every question. Yeah, yeah, exactly.
你仍然不会得到一个确定性的答案，因为你的问题是和其他人的问题批量处理的。而低级 Kuda 操作符会根据你周围的数据给出略有不同的答案。所以，所以是的，没有办法，零办法你可以保证确定性。啊，Tay，我学到了。是的，除非你在你自己的硬件上以 1 的批处理大小以一种非常有效的方式运行。而且你为每个问题等待一天。是的，是的，完全正确。
Okay, so we're just want to wrap up on this. You know, I get asked this a lot. You know, is software engineering dead? How is this going to work? Well, I have a job after we graduate. wait, you know, I have, I teach at UT now, and so tomorrow I have office hours, and I guarantee you tomorrow someone is going to ask me this. I know this because they emailed me today saying they're going to ask me tomorrow. Wait, that's not fair. But I get this every single week. And so,
好的，所以我们只是想总结一下。你知道，我经常被问到这个问题。你知道，软件工程死了吗？这会如何工作？好吧，我们毕业后我会有工作吗？等等，你知道，我，我现在在 UT 教书，所以明天我有办公时间，我保证明天有人会问我这个问题。我知道这一点，因为他们今天给我发了电子邮件说他们明天会问我。等等，那不公平。但我每周都会遇到这种情况。所以，
you know, my, I guess I'll give my overall take, and I love to hear your take, Patrick. it. I think that, you know, using a systematic way to solve problems, that is always going to be in demand, right? The demand for doing that has done nothing but go up. You know, I'd like to think that my great, great ancestors were also engineers, like building catapults and stuff. Maybe they weren't. Maybe they were tyrants. I don't know. Maybe they were bomb- Probably just died of dysentery, dude. But before they died of disintery, dude. But before they died a dysentery, they were making some pretty kick-ass trebushes. That's what I'd like to believe. But we actually work more hours than they did, right? Like, we work more hours than medieval peasants. And so clearly the demand for, the demand for like systematic thinking and turning, you know, abstract problems into like really concrete problems, that's not going away. what is going away
你知道，我的，我想我会给出我的总体看法，我很乐意听听你的看法，帕特里克。我认为，你知道，使用系统化的方式来解决问题，那将永远有需求，对吧？做这件事的需求只会上升。你知道，我喜欢认为我的曾曾祖先也是工程师，比如制造弹射器之类的东西。也许他们不是。也许他们是暴君。我不知道。也许他们是炸弹——可能只是死于痢疾，伙计。但在他们死于痢疾之前，伙计。但在他们死于痢疾之前，他们正在制造一些非常棒的投石机。这就是我愿意相信的。但我们实际上比他们工作的时间更长，对吧？比如，我们工作的时间比中世纪农民还长。所以显然对，对像系统化思维和将，你知道，抽象问题转化为像真正具体问题的需求，那不会消失。正在消失的是
is like the very wrote, you know, like I have this project in Java and I need to port it to C++ and that's going to take two years. Like that's going away. And so, um, and so, you know, maybe the supply of software engineering
像非常死记硬背的，你知道，比如我有这个 Java 项目，我需要把它移植到 C++，那需要两年时间。比如那正在消失。所以，嗯，所以，你知道，也许软件工程的供应
jobs actually does, does take a permanent hit. Um, but that was never really the point. The point, wasn't really to write software. The point was to build something cool. And if that, as long as we stayed true to that,
工作实际上确实，确实受到了永久性的打击。嗯，但这从来都不是重点。重点，并不是真正写软件。重点是构建一些很酷的东西。只要我们坚持这一点，
then there's always going to be a ton of opportunity. And if, you know, we have thousands of years of history showing that, you know, it's just going to get more busy for everybody. So, yeah, I, my, we sort of talked about it. I think like curiosity building. I mean, I think there's are things you. see throughout history like certain people had and the way they applied it was maybe
那么总会有大量的机会。而且如果，你知道，我们有几千年的历史表明，你知道，它只会对每个人变得更忙。所以，是的，我，我的，我们某种程度上谈论过它。我认为像好奇心构建。我的意思是，我认为有些事情你。在整个历史中看到某些人拥有，而他们应用它的方式也许
different. The opportunities for applying it were maybe different. But I mean, I think of all the things in the world that you can build, having, maybe call it style, like having the persnicketyness to keep through working
不同。应用它的机会也许不同。但是，我的意思是，我想到了世界上你可以构建的所有东西，拥有，也许称之为风格，比如拥有那种坚持不懈地继续工作的挑剔，
and forcing that it doesn't work the first time or didn't match what you expected. Like, the question would be, I guess, we were talking about SORA earlier. Someone was saying, you know, oh, Sorrel will kill Hollywood, right? Like, everybody will just watch their own, own movie. I don't actually think that's
并强迫它在第一次没有工作或没有达到你预期时。比如，问题是，我猜，我们之前在谈论 SORA。有人说，你知道，哦，Sora 会杀死好莱坞，对吧？比如，每个人都会只看他们自己的，自己的电影。我实际上不认为那是
true. Right. For me, the most likely outcome is a new, maybe order of magnitude, maybe two orders of magnitude, literally a hundred more creators and movies get made. But there are still ones that just like, like you were talking about drip boards. I wouldn't
真的。对吧。对我来说，最可能的结果是一个新的，也许是一个数量级，也许是两个数量级，字面上多一百个创作者和电影被制作出来。但仍然有一些只是，像你刚才谈论的滴水板。我不会
have had that idea, but I enjoyed it. Yeah. And so therefore, like, somebody had taste, like someone to call it whatever you want, I don't know. They had ambition to like prompt it to do that thing that I never would have. And I think the same will be true in software deciding what to build. Now it may not be that it may not be, I don't even say like fair in the same way that you just go to college, like get a good job and you're guaranteed in the same way that like, you know, you can hear the criticisms about, you know, 40 years ago. You did A, B, and C and you like,
有过那种想法，但我很享受。是的。所以，有人有品位，或者随便你怎么称呼它，我不知道。他们有雄心去推动它做我永远不会做的事情。我认为在决定构建什么软件时也是如此。现在，这可能并不意味着，我甚至不会说这就像你上大学、找份好工作那样公平，就像你听到的关于40年前的批评一样，你做了A、B和C，然后你就像，
you know, worked X years and then retired and it was a good like and that may not be true anymore. May or may not. I'm not here to say. I'm not trying to get on politics. There's like, there's no guarantee, like you're saying, you know, medieval peasants, it's completely different than us today,
你知道，工作了X年然后退休，那很好，但这可能不再适用了。也许是，也许不是。我不是来下定论的。我不想谈论政治。就像你说的，没有保证，就像中世纪的农民，这和我们今天完全不同，
you know, like things change. And so my take on software engineering is the skill set feels valuable, understanding how systems work, how they get built, how to debug stuff, right?
你知道，事物在变化。所以我对软件工程的看法是，这套技能很有价值，理解系统如何工作，如何构建，如何调试，对吧？
Like, this feels useful, but maybe there's less of a discrimination between learning it as a mechanical engineer an electrical engineer or a software engineer, maybe a lot like the lines blur because you can reach further outside your domain. But maybe there's a big difference
这感觉很有用，但也许作为机械工程师、电气工程师或软件工程师来学习它的区别变小了，也许界限变得模糊了，因为你可以触及到你领域之外更远的地方。但也许有很大的区别，
between how those people interact with tools like Claude less difference between them than working with an IDE, but then maybe someone who's a journalism student works with Cloud Code as well, but in a fundamentally sort of different interaction model, right? They're building something very different. They're building smaller things. They're building, you know,
在于这些人如何与Claude这样的工具交互，这与使用IDE的区别较小，但也许一个新闻系的学生也在使用Claude Code，但其交互模式从根本上是不同的，对吧？他们构建的东西非常不同。他们构建的东西更小。他们构建的是，你知道，
and maybe they don't want to buy the thing you're building, but maybe you're building for an end product. I think there's probably going to be seismic shifts, but it's very difficult to predict a specific shift. Yeah. That was a lot of words to say very little. Boom. Done.
也许他们不想买你正在构建的东西，但也许你是在为最终产品而构建。我认为可能会有巨大的转变，但很难预测具体的转变。是的。说了那么多废话。砰。结束了。
Throw the gauntlet down. Yeah. No, I think that makes a lot of sense. I mean, I think that, you know, for teachers, for all these folks to use quad code for their specific task. Oh, here's another thing. you know, we seem to have forgotten the importance of data and particularly data around user experience. You know, so, like, you hear people say, oh, I'll just make Salesforce myself for my company.
发起挑战。是的。不，我认为这很有道理。我的意思是，我认为，你知道，对于教师，对于所有这些人来说，使用Claude Code来完成他们的特定任务。哦，还有一件事。你知道，我们似乎忘记了数据的重要性，特别是关于用户体验的数据。你知道，所以，你会听到人们说，哦，我会为我的公司自己制作Salesforce。
And I'll save my company 100K a year. It's like, yeah, but Salesforce isn't just like a database and some front end code and back in code. It's also, you know, like a decade plus of user research. like, oh, you know, we, we allowed everyone to just add and delete people in Salesforce. And then some rogue employee just got pissed and wiped the whole Salesforce database for one of our clients. And we learned not to do that anymore. We learned, oh, we actually need our back. We need role-based access control.
我会为我的公司每年节省10万美元。这就像，是的，但Salesforce不仅仅是一个数据库、一些前端代码和后端代码。它还包括，你知道，十多年来的用户研究。比如，哦，你知道，我们允许每个人在Salesforce中添加和删除人员。然后一些流氓员工生气了，删除了我们客户的整个Salesforce数据库。我们学会了不再那样做。我们学会了，哦，我们实际上需要RBAC。我们需要基于角色的访问控制。
So that Joe Shimo, who, you know, is like entry level, who's an intern for the summer, you know, when his internship is over, that the last day he can't just go and download all the personal information out of Salesforce, right? So, like, that's a lesson they learned. And there's definitely, like, you know, they probably learned like 10 lessons a day for 10 years. They learned like tons of tons of lessons. And the AI is not going to have all those lessons
这样Joe Shimo，你知道，那个刚入职的实习生，当他的实习结束时，最后一天他不能直接去下载Salesforce里的所有个人信息，对吧？所以，这是一个他们学到的教训。而且肯定，你知道，他们可能每天学到10个教训，持续了10年。他们学到了无数的教训。而人工智能不会拥有所有这些教训，
because, you know, it's not going to be in the GitHub comments. You know, it's like Joe Shimo to wipe the database for Exxon Mobile on his last intern day. and that's why this code is here. Like, that's not there. So I don't think SaaS companies are dead. I don't think it, I think, I know companies that are like, we're going to cancel our Salesforce contract and in-house it.
因为，你知道，它不会在GitHub的评论里。你知道，就像Joe Shimo在实习的最后一天删除了埃克森美孚的数据库，这就是为什么这段代码在这里。这并不存在。所以我认为SaaS公司并没有死。我不认为，我认为，我知道有些公司说，我们要取消Salesforce合同，转为内部开发。
I expect that to be a complete and utter disaster, all sorts of weird security problems over the next 12 months. And ultimately for SaaS to make a comeback. And I'm not even in SaaS, but I have no horse in the race, but that's where I see it going. I also feel like it's a focus thing. like do you sales force is expensive but I think people are maybe too worried about some of the expenses is like if you can have focus and just outperform it right like is that really what
我预计那将是一场彻底的灾难，在接下来的12个月里会出现各种奇怪的安全问题。最终SaaS会卷土重来。我甚至不在SaaS行业，我没有利益相关，但我看到的就是这样。我也觉得这是一种专注力的问题。比如Salesforce很贵，但我认为人们可能太担心一些开支了，如果你能保持专注并超越它，对吧？这真的是你
you want people spending time on like even if it's easy I don't know I mean I don't know how it costs but it's like maybe it is for a certain size company or people like doing very low margin work but growing your margins is probably like finding a way to be more effective in some area rather than just like reduce costs. There's like always that balance, that tension in business. And you're right. I feel like it's overblown that suddenly it'll just make sense for everyone to do it.
想让人们花时间做的事情吗？即使这很容易，我不知道，我的意思是，我不知道成本如何，但也许对于某种规模的公司或者做低利润工作的人来说是这样，但提高利润率可能比仅仅降低成本更有效。商业中总是有那种平衡，那种张力。你是对的。我觉得突然间每个人都这样做是有道理的说法被夸大了。
Some people will. Like the total addressable market will probably go down when there's lots of companies who are just paying too much per seat, right? Like it's the total amount they spend, they can employ a small group of engineers to do this. But then in a bunch it just, it takes away
有些人会。比如总潜在市场可能会下降，因为有很多公司每个席位支付太多了，对吧？比如他们花费的总金额，他们可以雇佣一小群工程师来做这件事。但随后它会带走
focus. Right. Right. Yeah. Because when you say re-implement Salesforce, that's not good enough. You know what I mean? Like, you can't just go to an engineer and say, do that. Because Salesforce is enormous. You probably don't need all of it. And even if you did need all of it, how would you faithfully reproduce it? So chances are they say redo Salesforce and you end up with some janky thing that can't handle
专注力。对。对。是的。因为当你谈论重新实现Salesforce时，那是不够好的。你知道我的意思吗？你不能直接去找工程师说，做那个。因为Salesforce太庞大了。你可能不需要全部。即使你需要全部，你如何忠实地复制它？所以他们很可能会说重做Salesforce，结果你得到了一些无法处理负载的蹩脚东西，
load and just doesn't behave the way you expect. And guess what? It has no documentation either. Or if it does, it's AI generated. And it hasn't been looked at. that and reviewed by a person. This is broken. Talk to Claude.
而且表现不如预期。你猜怎么着？它也没有文档。或者如果有，它是人工智能生成的。而且没有经过人工查看和审查。这坏了。去和Claude谈谈。
Talk to, talk to GPT. There we go. Open AI. Ring, ring, ring. Sam Altman. Can you fix my?
去和GPT谈谈。就是这样。OpenAI。铃铃铃。Sam Altman。你能修复我的吗？
Oh, my gosh. So, yeah, I mean, I'm not a betting person, but I would probably try to buy the dip on SaaS. I don't,
天哪。所以，是的，我的意思是，我不是一个赌徒，但我可能会尝试在SaaS低谷时买入。我不，
again, I don't know where it is. I wouldn't try to try to convince anyone that they could time the market, but it just feels like, feels like SaaS is a little underrated at the moment.
再说一次，我不知道它在哪里。我不会试图说服任何人他们可以把握市场时机，但感觉SaaS目前被低估了。
All right. So yeah, we will definitely cover OpenClawe. Someone requested that. There's been a lot of requests for things adjacent to this. We wanted to really set the foundation, talk about the history behind this, and build the sort of first floor of this tower that we're building on this topic.
好的。所以是的，我们肯定会涵盖OpenClaude。有人要求过。关于这个话题有很多相关的请求。我们想真正打好基础，谈谈背后的历史，并为我们正在讨论的这个话题建立这座塔的第一层。
So hope you all appreciated it. And yeah, we'll catch you all later. All right. See you next time. Music by Eric Barndollar. Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Share-A-Like 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work to remix and adapt the work, but you must provide an attribution to Patrick and I and share alike and kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
所以希望你们都喜欢。是的，我们以后再聊。好的。下次见。音乐由Eric Barndollar创作。Programming Throwdown根据知识共享署名-相同方式共享2.0许可协议分发。您可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品以进行混音和改编，但您必须注明Patrick和我的署名，并以相同方式共享。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。